we got dance soda ladies and gentlemen
to Monday I hope you're all ready I'm
you don't know who Dan Soder I'm here to
educate you
he's a town's finest he's the funniest
comic out of Colorado or a Colorado but
here's the thing he's a New York comic
and he has a special drop in this
Saturday on HBO 10:00 p.m. before we do
that though I want you guys come out to
Phoenix
December 21st at the celebrity theater
then I got Wilbur New Year's Eve I got
the Wilbur theater in Boston get your
tickets at th kake.com Brendan where you
can only be in Kansas City this Friday
and Saturday at The Improv Kansas City
improv this Friday Saturday the next
Saturday
come laugh with me at the Borgata casino
Atlantic City one night only December
14th I'm doing my hour of comedy with my
friend and then I'm sticking around
watching the big UFC fight with you guys
as well Atlantic City Borgata New Jersey
La Hoya economy store December 19th to
21st and after that go to this site
there's a shitload of dates I'm tired
already t fat K calm it's rock rock with
your [ __ ] out Monday as you know you're
eating a handful of nuts now we got
dance soda coming in got Dan soda
monster company's got to come out of
Colorado in a long time funniest guy so
watch pink you didn't know that couple a
town boys really couple roaring roar
'voice roar boys same content to rival
high school now Smoky Hill I'm over the
Trailblazers over here I think of Daniel
York comic but I guess he's Colorado boy
he came up in the scene in New York but
he's a medium or Colorado boy yeah you
went to a rival high school smoky hill
what's that means you guys drive in the
snow what's that mean no if he just out
of hand huh love to slap his stupid smug
Hill face why yeah because you got some
rivalry going rivalry we used to I don't
think my team ever lost to his team and
I'm pretty sure you played football too
you play football
pretty sure big kid I'm gonna take him
in I look forward to taking you never
met Dan huh never met anybody takes men
so funny he is very special coming out
on HBO that's why I serve promoting it I
think I've met Dan his voice he taught
he talks like like the killer off of
science of the Lambs
I don't know that would be Hannibal
Lecter which one was your toe I'm
talking about the deep voice the deep ID
father sighs oh he's so such a deep
voice funny sure I've never did him big
Jay oakerson have a show shout out big
Jay
I was showing serious radio when I was
promoting my special I did it I thought
I I loved Anna love big jam like here's
just another radio spot dude I've never
laughed so hard in my life it was the
three of us narrating what the guys were
saying on the cats predator how it was
gonna go down and there it was so
[ __ ] funny Jerry's a [ __ ] monster
we got to get him on we do gotta get big
um that's great
the bonfire the bonfire ice thing was
the bomb fire there's so many words in
the English language that we [ __ ] up all
the time no I mean you know you know the
Disney sign since I was probably I think
it's sixth grade I figured out I thought
it was a G right that's that's
bring it up let me say so I was like God
if it's Disney why do they have a G well
you know his new yeah you know I'll see
how to Disney I obviously had a learning
disability of the kid oh I thought that
was a G I thought it's a G this here oh
yeah I see that as a D because it's all
pronounced Disney not just no I know but
she is Lee would be a little weird oh
you do I don't you want to go to J's D
and jasny a lot of jizz cheese NEMA
basically summers that be the happiest
porn porn iasts place on earth oh yeah
this is DS house glory hole yeah his
knee see if that was a G for a long time
for the longest I don't clearly a
learning disability know what that's all
right and then I Romero's in sixth grade
I stare at some Isaac that's a D that's
a D class right well good luck in life
dude good luck in life well that's a
real thing you do you don't have
dyslexia though I'm sure I suffer from a
number of things yeah but so don't we
all I am [ __ ] positive that I would
have been a case for Ritalin or
something oh yeah I mean they had such
major I had such major but they like I'm
gonna dull now can you imagine me when I
was a big did I comment on the head it
goes
yeah I'm a semi adult your age right but
can you at 52 years to kind of get it
together can you imagine me can you
[ __ ] imagine me when I was 14 when I
was 18 I remember coming to Charlie to
boarding school when I was in I went to
yeah that's what happened when I was all
die [ __ ] it's all making sense now yeah
your dad like what my dad wanted to send
me Tasmanian Devil out of he wanted to
send me to military school I was so good
choice a hundred percent I get able to
put your ass right in line I was such a
[ __ ] I'm with your parents on this at
first I think that's [ __ ] up for them
to do now I've been around you for about
nine you hella eight years now yeah
Papo save me a town tip to the hat to
you although what saved me was two
things one I liked getting good at
something so I would obsess over one
thing and - I liked routine it gave me a
sense yeah but but but it gave me I said
so I didn't mind daily attendance in
practice but as you only then saved me
because I was a pure tip I'm like God
even though you're like I had to stand
up in class stand because I she wouldn't
let me sit because I didn't work either
though did it no though teachers always
made you stand if you're too fidgety
yeah I did nothing never draw attention
to me yeah
stay on the rule but I was I definitely
could use some vyvanse ritalin whatever
the [ __ ] they do kids I'm just
spitballing ideas here with your mental
health why not just get a little Ritalin
see how it goes
oh I took some vyvanse here we go I'm
glad yes took some guy said I was
talking about how I have ADHD and stuff
dude gives me he goes take this it's
vyvanse I take it her I was talking on
stage and in in Seattle no in a [ __ ]
Spokane and he goes dude I I suffer from
that if you tried vyvanse I go no he
goes try it gives it to me I take it
yeah I took he goes just to start with
half a you know whatever does bro I I
was on cocaine I was in on the plane I
was like oh this is great I was looking
out the window I was like this is
fantastic I want the flight four hours
only this is great so but was this
supposed to give you more folks to pay
yeah it depends on who you are and it
depends on it so some kids you give them
a stimulant it actually has the opposite
he calms him down and focuses on weird
yeah it can be very I talked to this
therapist who who did many primary
studies with kids and they're you know
ritalin these things get a bad rap
however he said he looked at me and he
goes look I've been around at my whole
life
they absolutely save some kids like I
told you with obstructing this doctor
about my son with his seizures and CBD
oil
he was completely against CBD oil but
since I gave my son shout out to Peter
spectrum since I gave him the CBD oh
there's been none doctors keep unit to
him yeah he goes if that works for you
do it yes I I don't recommend it most
any my patients he is I don't know I
can't tell you to go take this other you
know medication that Kai has all these
side of yeah were you giving this now
there's none I had a guy a doctor a
medical doctor I you know how if that
that I'm all tense in my neck between my
clavicle and my mic trap like it's all
bunched up there and you said so he said
he said muscle relaxants you can take
anti-inflammatories he goes CBD oil when
it's the one-to-one ratio
he said he's a doctor medical doctor
here's I think it's great if we try it
yeah
did you try I didn't I just took I told
my well I know a guy who owns one of the
biggest CBD companies in the world and
they have one to one it's the best you
can get okay take it easy
can I get some all right don't make a
fist like that
man you're getting aggressive on a
Monday we've only had one [ __ ] cup of
coffee you know I do now every coffee
doesn't matter day or night I only do
red eyes now what's a red eye with a
shot all right take it easy
it's a drip with a shot of expresso yeah
gonna put some hair on your [ __ ]
chest but it makes you taste better huh
oh I can't get strong enough for me
there's no coffee in the world strong
enough I'll tell you that on it and
black rifle collab caffeine I drink
about six cups low yesterday before my
workout yeah you're not bad to lay down
the floor pop it lay down the floor
uh-huh a bit faster right yeah pop out
lay down floor oh you've been fat I
didn't know you moving like a
hummingbird
aren't moving like a hummingbird also
lose yes sorry ladies and gentlemen
Oh
yeah oh man see you [ __ ] knew your
awareness do Aurora in the house you're
surrounded by a real we know about
chambers road I live when you know my
love what do you know about Utah pool
boys take your shirt off oh don't worry
it's Rick it's a do you thought Aurora
is just for school shootings I don't
know bro that's odor we all know movie
theater shootings are what we do in a
town yeah we let Littleton do the school
shooting yeah
dorks do brings a gun to school you
dorks we do it the movies losers I get
to the Aurora mall like you're supposed
to go to mr. rags
go shoot up kids by engine shame area
you know we played high school football
against each other you did he played it
overland he was an Overland Trail Blazer
and I was a smoky old buff s HHS senator
what position did you play
I played outside linebacker I wasn't
good mmm it was good I was not good did
you remember him no but I remember this
is crazy about Brendan I remember he
played at University of Colorado I was
obsessed with the video game NCAA
college football yeah and they used to
put names on the players like this good
like real dork [ __ ] yeah you could take
a memory card and somewhere to come back
with like you know college kids it's
illegal to put their names on one kid
would put the whole roster and I ran a
dynasty and Shaab was upon it as my
fullback what's wrong did you play with
brown with crisp with uh it was older
than me
Bobby purify Bobby purify man you're on
a squad which means you were on that
team that beat Nebraska 6235 the year
before me that was Chris Brown but we
never I'm trying to think I don't think
we never lost Nebraska yeah yeah you
with Lawrence Vickers Loren speakers I
love that when he merits when he
narrates that amazing I don't know what
that person I've ever met
that's Colorado I was about I was a type
of video that
they had mort's do and it's this play
and it's see you for CSU yes playwright
truck this dude and Lord struck this
dude did you it was at Invesco no that
was at [ __ ] Marla Folsom okay yeah
but we both truck and he's there in it
but he's getting the kids hyped up Wow
if I ask you a question eight inches we
just [ __ ] saw free y'all soft so I'm
not him Lawrence Vickers oh no he's
working with a regular piece oh I was
like Jesus Christ why are you in combat
you should just be doing it you should
be to an inspirational post on instagram
body lean enough mouth soft that sounds
almost inconvenient ain't that ain't
that certain some guys probably Vickers
had a dude like I tell you you talk
doing like a mic yeah what were you
saying though Gary Barnett shout - Gabe
Burnett shout-out Gary Barnett you were
there for those live ass parties yeah be
in with you guys okay so let me explain
because he was a Katy night you'll shout
out dr. Dave night on Channel seven
local news doctor his daughter was a
kicker on see you you see use football
program top he wouldn't bring to put
their top ten top ten football team yeah
then it comes out these [ __ ]
are having wild parties with a strippers
[ __ ] dude
oh they're all these boosters are coming
in being like come to Colorado and then
bringing in like [ __ ] it strippers and
it made me like the Buffs more of course
it made you like the Buffs more of
course it did and part of me just died
because I'm not I wasn't big enough for
young enough to have played on that
Canadian Ida who blew up the team got
Gary brunette fired well she she liked
the way the dick taste yeah well she was
a Cady NIDA she was a kicker at the
University of Colorado feel high school
she was a quatre field shout-out Dave
Logan she lived it blew the lid off the
parties she well she basically you know
came I was like I'm being sexually
harassed University of Colorado and then
journalists looked into it and they're
like yeah you guys are these top running
backs have you
mother have you seen K United no smoke -
is she she's hot all right all I
remember is watching the local news
footage of her being like ad LaBeouf's
have done something no team has done how
did a female player just hurt kicking
field goals she's how to [ __ ] oh my god
what uh she was good that good at
kicking field goals she was at d1 kicker
do you want kicker oh okay yeah all
right
extra points great extra points well
that's what you would get Gary Brian
expired if he goes well she's not very
good and then everyone's there like why
don't you play he's like well she's not
very good and then it's like how do you
sex yeah and then the investigators like
the shame a light oh my god there's
semen everywhere this locker room yeah
you gotta understand you see you is
getting guys that were like supposed to
go to [ __ ] Florida State and we're
supposed to go to like USC and they're
like I'm going to Colorado no why are
you going to Colorado party yeah I know
like have you been to the parties in -
she ruined everything
she was kind of the the one that she was
the she was the spark plug down yeah but
you're a match she's the match that lit
the fire yeah you're well you're a gal
Ayanna all guys I mean couldn't be more
of a male dominated I think football
like football locker rooms everyone
should play football just for the
feeling of a locker room to feel how
terrifying isolating and hilarious it is
well ski was she was hilarious she's the
number one ski when she was actually
ranked here so that's a difference
shares her story of making oh yeah
surviving right well she was raped and I
not in at sea that's a New Mexico Lobos
thing yeah that's
oh yeah she transferred yeah they raped
down in New Mexico Colorado do they pay
for sex in order Hey yeah dude it was
like caught like football locker rooms
you see how hilarious everyone is and
the true racial divide of the boom box
if people got to put on no limit or
Metallica you knew who was running the
show yeah usually the white old linemen
would put on metallic all death metal
all death metal all like Kid Rock was
huge with like fat white linemen if you
have acne on your triceps you're
fighting to get to that boom box they
put on like [ __ ] Power Man five
and then like you knew if it was like
triple six mafia you're like well it
looks like the Safety's got there today
look like Brian Calhoun Oh DJ Screw oh
no one wants to admit it they're like
there's no racial divides either yeah it
doesn't there's a one there's there's
always like a few kids who can mix go
play for both teams that was me yeah
most my friends were black yeah and it's
like you could mix but in general it's
very White's over here blacks over here
together it's the big whites it's like
the big big white yeah and then it's
like you know like a quarterback could
be over there like trying to talk to his
receivers and you're like yeah we know
what you're doing you know it's pretty
sick is he okay I was just straight out
there yeah I just I sucked it was funny
enough that everyone liked me you know
what I mean I go to sodas room these
doing prank phone calls I was just
taking a little break the bridge rom-com
you know you you can you can if you if
you know what you're doing you can be
accepted yeah if you didn't make like
like two of the guys I made laughs yeah
we're Bloods and I was just like cool
everyone like everyone likes a clown
yeah yeah clown because the clown says I
got no blowing this harmless harmless
harmless there for a good time and it
really was it was the thing where I was
like oh I'm funny enough that no one
will like try to hurt me
yeah but I'm also like I sucked enough
at football that it was still an ego
every time I got that [ __ ] do you
start in Denver
did you I I started my junior like two
games against Milan side did a shout out
to Mullen Mullen by the way blowin
Lester's blowing the doors off I think
we lost 49 to nothing I don't remember
the running back Johnny rough yo yeah
and both Scaife boat dude I lined up
against Alex Smith only late at Stanford
and for Jake Anderson
before I went on those guys when I say I
grew up without a dad but I had a dad
that game I had two dads that I was
raised by two loving caring dad that
would grab me by my chest plate of my
[ __ ] shoulder pads and just throw me
into the ground
and then you get up and you're like wow
I see you Johnny rough one for like 200
yards against me because I like just
pitch in to this kid and I was like guys
he's talking about went on to like play
war fell yeah Alex mr. Bhalla here's how
come and I was just boy at a prom in
high school especially at that level of
space I'm all in or other but close yeah
he's a black guy yeah blood the black
Alex Smith is called but the thing is
you got that guy who's I mean he's going
to play for Stanford gone to break
records versus a guy who's never gonna
play again yo dude my senior year you
line up against it's just like right
there that's the kid by the way that's
the guy had to line up on let's play
that's hilarious
yes so out different this is how this is
how funny what my mom just didn't come
to games she's I neither really came up
to what I'll do against a guy he just
does whatever he wants and ghosts like
600 yards and then they pull him cuz
they blow you out then yeah they pull
him to their one get hurt they don't do
that that's the thing that hurts is when
they're like hey you're doing too well
take a break and me I'm like I gotta
take a bath and Ebsen salt afterwards
just cuz I'm like everything [ __ ]
it's so important though for a guy the I
can always see dudes who have no idea
yeah see guys that just don't know you
can get handled that you can get handled
by a man and and you may not know what
that guy that guy could look like
but sometimes the guy can look like the
UPS guy not available not info not but
let me tell you what they don't look
like the UPS no I mean obviously you're
like oh oh oh I probably should move on
yes start reading you right away I'm
gonna get I'm gonna get my house like
yeah I'm gonna get good at Madden yeah
well I know so much faster but Brian
what you're saying is you know who has
that hockey player's hockey player
you'll be at a bar and you're like who's
this [ __ ] nerd and then you're like
you watch him just light up four dudes
and well I was in I was hung out with
the Blackhawks yeah to a man
they're not as big as football players
it's so obvious they're athletes though
yeah I would say MMA is better like if
you saw if you're let's say a barbed
screen saw Kenny Florian yeah like hey
nerd yeah [ __ ] pipe down and I choked
you the funny get [ __ ] I'm never
watching Forrest Griffin on the first
Ultimate Fighter and I'm like this is
the guy you're watching trading like Oh
Horace in person is a big horse again
big but he's long even be like this yeah
yeah and then he's just [ __ ] signet
ring what's funny about guys like forest
is as athletic as big as he is probably
not a d1 level football player excuse me
I don't know no no right yeah right no I
mean maybe but no not even close
really I don't know physically he looks
like he could be but here's the thing
Shaw played you played big 12 football
yes when Cu was a top 10 team in the
[ __ ] nation played that national
champs Texas and Oklahoma you're gonna
get soaked Lahoma Sean's a real athlete
yeah but I'm saying like you when you're
on the field with them you're like so do
you see the difference what we're
talking about the difference in high
school
do you see that in college where you're
like across from a guy like Adrian
Peterson Adrian Peterson freshman at
Oklahoma and they're like no I saw it
was like night he's gonna be a
first-round draft pick yeah I know I
don't you play against Anderson yeah I
know I'm Jason Peterson and Jason might
both Heisman Trophy winners B is 53
Kansas City not a big deal
I'm there this weekend should be a
better time in Arrowhead in air head
coldest [ __ ] beat the [ __ ] out but when
I see Adrian Peterson or these other
big-name guys I was more like alright
well they're gonna be first-round draft
pick yeah I'm not them but I can get in
there yeah you you clearly got to uh
who's the guy who said he played in the
NFL seven years it was a center he's in
the radio show
Oh Matt my chest Matt Matt said that you
were matt said the only reason you
didn't get go where you
should have gone in the nfl's just you
weren't seen by the right guys timing
and there's a lot of that is that a big
thing of like if you don't if the right
guy cuz my friend one of my friends I
grew up with is a coach for the 49ers
and he finds guys and then my age too
yeah Kyle went to Crete cow went to
Creek they played receiver Creek my
buddy Mike McDaniel who played at Smoky
Hill is the run game coordinator and he
finds guys like Matt Breda or Moss or do
where they're like guys that no one in
the NFL's like I don't want Matt Bri dad
a Georgia Southern and my buddy who's a
righty you know controls the running
game for the 49ers it's like I need this
guy yeah this guy's great huh and then
he takes off when he gets to the league
but got no looks coming out of Georgia
Southern which is a bottom level d1
point another example that's Julian
Edelman yeah like he didn't get he was a
ball in high school no one draft him and
then I think Toledo or I forget who did
yeah he put in place and played junior
college and then and then the only
Division one team that took him they
just playing quarterback and then the
New England Paige didn't get no one
wanted him and then doing a page like I
think we could use this guy somewhere
yeah I mean he's a here's the thing
about joining elderman he's a Hall of
Fame he's a Hall of Fame he's a Hall of
Famer he's gonna be a Holly Holly Brady
shut yelling screaming at him that's
right that's the relationship yeah yeah
but you got to know like they was he
saying there was he yelling at hammer
was I don't know they I think that
happens more in the NFL than people
realize like when when my buddy Mike
coached in Atlanta I'd always ask Mike
cuz I'm fast I love football
I still love football even though I
sucked at it you kind of love it more
when you because you're like I just love
you just know how good they are
and I always ask Mike I'm like who was
the most impressive person you coached
and he was like Julio Jones
I was the receivers coach in Atlanta for
Julio and he's like Julio Jones and I'm
like what made him so good because I
just love that kind of questions what
did you see that you know maybe we don't
see his fans he's like he can find the
ball better than any receiver I've ever
coached so it means the ball goes up
some guys are just stuck to their route
yeah they just run their route but Julio
could adjust get to the ball and go and
pull it down and he's like my favorite
thing is he would [ __ ] Matt Ryan
if Matt Ryan ever threw it to him double
covered he would immediately come to the
sidelines back what the [ __ ] are you
doing I'm double covered someone's open
and you never realize that that's just a
common
the side lat Julio Jones he's based in
NFL player says he's the biggest freak
on the field he played at Alabama yeah I
can freak but Larry Fitzgerald oh yeah
that they have a miked up and it's this
year when the plan Atlanta Falcons oh
his quarterback the baller from Oklahoma
yeah Marie Marie come over you scum ray
goes pay attention when this guy's on
the field you'll never see anything like
it again yes he's the biggest freak out
here what did you see anyone at like
that when you're on the field with him
you're like I'll never be on a field
like anybody like that uh the one guy
who I was like oh is he human would be
Santana Moss yeah I am II yeah yeah they
feel balm like COD terrible ball and he
jumped up and comment oh my god and when
Brennan before I kind of when I was here
I would always talk about I have a
friend I go he's a great athlete yeah I
mean this guy and Brennan would go Brian
he didn't do where'd he play so well he
was gonna play d1 but what happened he
just you got to stop saying yeah because
it's such a different thing because when
you do four years of d1 football [ __ ]
let alone pros did my new my new
favorite TV my new favorite TV I can't
believe on this length of the game last
chance to you oh you know what that
Coach you see season water last chance
you you see that D tackle and you're
like this kids blowing everyone out then
you see him on Hard Knocks and he
doesn't make it to debut not good you
know clear and they're like it happened
like this Gruden goes Gruden said
something like hey let's get these some
of these [ __ ] guys you guys come on
the prize get him out of give him the
[ __ ] out of here that's it but yeah my
question to use is the NFL one of those
places where you can kind of go D to
Lodi one and no one's giving you a shot
because of high school and you've got
like look at like a guy like George
Kittel for the Niners stud stud but at
Iowa tall skinny people kind of overlook
him even when he got drafted people are
like all right George Kindle and now he
was still a high draft pick though yeah
you're riding around I think your first
round but does it make what a Mackey I
think he's a baller yeah but there's
guys he's a tight end he's so clean he's
the [ __ ] shout out to white Titan I
mean white 10s we can catch hey what's
up well thanks for the throwback
dude thanks for the
but is there no white running yeah white
running back lasts six games Oh
McCaffrey
yeah Christian McCaffrey oh you you
might wear tight end
what was your well tie it in like a CH
back do you play fullback too right yeah
you as fast as most tight ends or or
Sarah four six eight that's [ __ ]
that's best to [ __ ] for six months got
your size moving that fast that's
purifying that's yes that's fastest [ __ ]
I don't trouble with that yeah but I
always think about guys who are a low
level d1 yeah then they blow up he and a
fellow exception though innit yeah
exception it's like the guy who's
working at Ralph's right now who's like
been on a million [ __ ] auditions
hasn't happened eight years ago Morgan
Freeman worked at Ralph's yeah I know
yeah no yeah water playing arena
football Mike well that was always good
that was always like the louis c.k story
you know where he was like i was doing
comedy and then all of a sudden it broke
in like 2007 it's like you were winning
Emmys writing for [ __ ] Conan in the
90s I mean did your stand-up didn't blow
up yeah well you were no high level you
were like you were winning [ __ ] award
you're writing for the Chris Rock show
on HBO like and he was in he was in the
inner circle with Christmas always in he
was always everyone know but then also
with louis c.k it's like he's starting
was like you got a bomb 10,000 times
before you're a real comedian and you
know was like that's your path yeah he's
that he keeps spitting that knowledge
like [ __ ] there's there's a great book
called talent is overrated in the guy
the guy the author of it takes the look
at Malcolm Gladwell's 10,000 hours
things and he goes yeah but it's a great
thing of like you could do 10,000 hours
and still suck asses all right well
first of all 10,000 hours means it's
it's very misleading because you have to
be practicing the right way you gotta
roll that oh this book you get really
good at the wrong thing yeah you know if
you're not careful so even if you're
doing 10,000 hours but it's something
not good at right yeah I mean 30,000 it
doesn't matter this book is I recommend
it for everybody it's a super [ __ ]
dry read but it's really great because
what he does is he does do that exact
thing where he talks about applied
practice a great book yeah you have to
you have to basically practice the thing
that you saw
until it's great to just booster that's
it that's way more talent yes
so he'll break up he'll bring a practice
like this so the difference between say
regional swimmers and Olympic swimmers
is actually not time in the pool and
it's not even so much talent a lot of
times what it is is that when you have
an amazing coach that coach will say to
you okay today your hand is coming out
your elbows coming out this high I need
your elbow this high for a week they'll
only practice that yeah and and and so
so Roger Federer so they only would be
the coaching he's the coaching so Roger
Federer so they think yeah Roger Federer
practices an hour and a half a day now
now the way well but even back in the
day one of the reasons why these guys
because see it's and you know probably
know this but these you can practice six
hours day then you start getting injured
yeah so you've got it you have a little
bit of time yeah so you have a little
bit of time so what they'll do now
especially with tennis which is a lot of
physical you know yeah is is they have
you they very [ __ ] specific very
specific about and then the rest is just
timing keeping your timing where it is
and everything else so that unit is
overrated and he goes through he kind of
goes through like he goes through Jerry
Rice he has a chapter on Jerry Rice
about how Jerry Rice fastest but he
would run those hills because he wanted
to stay fresh in the fourth quarter he
would he would have those hand grasping
rakes and people would be like why are
you doing that he'd always walk around
like that he's like so I can take the
ball away from people that don't have as
strong as hands because people aren't
working there has an obsession that it's
an obsession and it's like Brady's not
right apparently yeah training and
that's where he's like Tiger Woods was
another so you're saying just out
working there saying in the right way
smarter
so saying like work on like well after I
read that book I was like all right I
don't sit down and write jokes well so
let me do that until I'm better at
sitting down so how are you doing it I
was just you know I would rip something
and then I'll write down like a line and
then I go on this rage but then you go
on stage and the only time you're
working on it is when you're on stage
which can be highly effective but I was
like well what's my weakness and that's
sitting down and writing out the jokes
cuz I'd hang out with people like Sam
Morril
who's like unbelievable any so funny but
also can sit down and be like up up and
you're like I I can't
pull from that I can't I would do it now
that guys doesn't feel right but then
you you sit in it and you do it enough
and you start it's like deep practice
they did with musicians they're like
world-class violinist world-class piano
players they will you you have to work
on what you're bad at yeah you're great
oh great you can do all that and then
they make you do these weird things with
your left hand that hurts your hands
yeah that's where they go that's where
you're wrong that's where that you're
not doing so those decisions yeah so you
just you focus on what you're bad at
that's also where people it's funny
saying about stand-up though because I
was sitting around thinking about
metaphors like I'm bad it I'm not as
good at coming up with metaphors yeah so
I've been I've been doing exactly that
just sitting down and kind of going the
next step you ask the next question yeah
I did writing wise did you read the book
yeah see it's great yeah and you got it
and you got if you have to fail you have
to fail a lot at it to kind of you know
then you start getting better and then
when you get that little bit of
progression you're like oh [ __ ] I can't
even do this now I can and then it gets
you hyped to be like let me do it more
and that's why I think the danger of
when comics gets super successful is
they start getting insulated by people
that don't be like hey your left hands
off you know what I mean like a musician
like a musician when they blow up
they're like everything you're playing
isn't perfect yeah like no I mean you
still have weaknesses so it's I think
that's like important when you see when
you see comics and like why are they not
funny anymore and it's like well because
they're keep that he lost an edge though
but it was people around him that are
like man you're so funny is supposed to
be like I live with my Kentucky own
who's like he's [ __ ] funny
funniest I just saw him in New York I'm
with dove and speculate about your age
and I go and I'm watching him and let's
go back there I go hold on I gotta watch
Becky own yeah [ __ ] kills dude he is
a he is I mean what I say - really yes
my roommate he's an air-tight comedian
Oh airtight kindig was like it was like
an Italian kid looks like a cop looks
like a gangster arrest yeah in high
school yeah Russell the Penn State Oh a
wrestler Penn State yeah that's a big
deal and he's we've lived together for
like eight and a half years right guy
but he's a guy where I'm like oh yeah
dude we live we live in my Queens I live
in the gym dude you guys date her yeah I
mean we're all common-law husband's
thick kid yeah he's a Penn State yeah
and you guys you guys met in New York
yeah I mean we've been friends just
through comedy or whatever how'd you get
from Denver to New York I just growing
up in Denver and you can imagine there's
really
no there's like no creative outlet for
if you want to be a comic comedy works
there's comedy works but there's no like
see my face comes up that's how
common-law husband we are my face comes
up when you see our there's that's
vacuum yeah yeah yeah I interrupted you
tell me about what I'm saying like Becky
owns a guy were you I can constantly
check jokes with him mm-hmm
as opposed to if I was by myself and he
just had a lot of yes people around you
and you're like how do you see one
through this joke he's the one you gotta
keep people around you that are kind of
like dude I hate to say this this you're
down to seller right yeah yeah and so
you're just like you guys is there any
better place is there any better place
to incubate the same better the stand is
up there man where's that in New York
it's in Union Square at the stand yeah
man they they kind of came the sellers
great and I love to sell our work and so
but having the stand and the seller it's
kind of like having two gyms where you
can go and Patrick who books the stand
what I love about him is this Jesus is
open for you to fail he's like just go
try whatever you want there's to rule by
ya dude it's great love they just open
the new one and it's [ __ ] beautiful
mom kid how the [ __ ] did you get to New
York from Denver so I I don't think
Denver and you can attest to this is
growing up in Denver it's it's great
it's like one of it was such the perfect
place to grow up in Aurora it was like
suburb middle-class suburbs
I just was real lucky about where I grew
up and when it came time to go to
college all my friends go to CSU all my
friends were gonna see you
or or community and I kind of found out
to Metro shout out Metro Metro Road
Runners I was just gonna say shout out
the Metro Road Runners down there on
auroria but I was kind of like if I stay
in Colorado and I go to college in
Colorado I'm gonna live in Colorado I'm
a family of Colorado because there's not
much things didn't everything does that
that's everyone does and instead of live
by the way I don't blame anybody for
that it's [ __ ] great I love seeing my
friends when I go home but I was like
let me leave Colorado for college and
then it'll just be easier for life for
me to leave so I went to the University
of Arizona I just why don't I had a
friend of a friend it was that went
there and it was kind of like hey I'll
go down there and I not walking hated it
oh wow I went down there yes you where
was it Tucson
I went down there I had
no money and I thought it was gonna be
like Boulder I thought was gonna be
house parties red cups kegs everyone
sitting around smoking shitty weed and
then I went down there and it was like
credit cards vodka sodas Range Rovers
it's all these rich kids from San Diego
in Long Island and they come down there
and they just got dad's money and I was
kind of like me [ __ ] this and so I
started working at the radio station and
I always wanted to know I wanted to be a
comedian so I started doing open mics at
laughs in college yeah like 20 21 and
then it was like the second I showed up
at the comedy club I was like this these
are my people here we go these are alike
dude Theo came through like I think my
first year in a comedy he was starting
and I met Theo in like 2005 where mm
yeah 2005 him coming through and he was
featuring oh wow
it was just one of those things where it
was like I loved it but then when it I
knew I needed to leave Tucson after I
graduated U of A cuz my mom was like
just please get it so we doing a bunch
of satsang going to school I was yeah I
was doing I was I was working weekends
like I would MC at like Albuquerque
laughs and then drive back or I was
doing like a lot of casino gigs in
Arizona yeah like a Honda Casino desert
diamond you could just go work these
places and it kind of sucked but it was
stage time and I got good and then I was
I kind of got good at being shitty you
get good at being shamed because I'm
moving yeah the right direction yeah and
then it was like LA or New York and I
just always had grown up idolizing like
New York comedy I love tough crowd like
Opie and Anthony putting me on to like
Patrice and Burr and all those guys and
I kind of was like my car was a piece of
[ __ ] I didn't have any money and I was I
was gonna move to New York and I just
moved to New York and like mm beginning
of 2007 and it just clicked I just liked
it I liked that I could ride the train
for 250 you get to like three different
clubs and they bring it until 4:00 in
the morning didn't get a DUI I
definitely what I got DUI if I moved to
LA hundred percent I what ahead of you I
like your Boozer I love dad enough that
I'd quit oh you did yeah yeah six years
ago yeah quitter
yeah just cuz dude he's a new drinker
now oh yeah I heard from a little birdie
that on Philadelphia buy your second
show you were a little toasty
the show you were toasted up I may be
dancing were you a jerk in high school
college no never
Danny's a whiskey gentleman didn't drink
now I won't do a set without a shot of
whiskey at least a shot so my first to
dizzy doubles yo man my first yeah you
sip on stage oh yeah until I quit
drinking until 2013 I would do a shot
and a beer before every set and that's
how you started no that was just do not
come from a family of drink that's what
I'm saying like no that's you do your
set with that right yeah and then dude
I've had blackout sets like Seattle or
just the next day you're like what he
have it on the tentacle ripped it
that's the secret and then you're waking
up like shaky and suicidal and you're
like yeah you know what maybe I
shouldn't [ __ ] do this
but I drank I just watched my parents be
alcoholics and I was like you know what
I'm a smoke weed I was a big pothead in
high school and I was like I'm just
gonna [ __ ] smoke and I stayed smoking
weed but then I started drinking and
when I went to Arizona when you grew up
in Colorado you grow up at altitude so
you grow up drinking at a level where
there's less oxygen in your brain you
can handle it dude I went down to
Arizona like a [ __ ] superfight the
tank
dude I was putting people away waiting I
drank like I did two tours in Nam I was
thrown aback and they're like I could
tell you about Danang you want to know
about the river and it was like I was at
the comedy club at 21 drinking with
dudes with real problems
yeah hanging with real problems not you
that this [ __ ] drinking bill is
[ __ ] fun what what Ted what was your
drink of choice shot of Jameson in a
blood heavy sea I just do I I don't want
the the calories from the beer so I just
do the you just the whiskey but you like
ha Jojo Brennan's a gentleman yeah
Brennan Brennan's not gonna drink a
cheap whiskey
yeah well Randall get himself some
Blanton's might even get himself some
Pappy who he doesn't [ __ ] around I was
like Tullamore Dew I was like what do
you want came later in the game where
you're not a messenger master shot
he's gentleman so why'd you I was
waiting tables for five years in by the
way shout out cabron these you wanna
who's leaving yours bro those are my
fave
you do it leave in these around can have
a man we can dbest friends
what do you have sweet teeth - I love
Dumber former alcoholic that's all you
do is when you quit drinking all you
want to do is eat sugar at night
we're obviously cuz all I did is eat
sugar now I'm big that's why you alright
yeah okay I just saw a beard - okay
boomer but it was it was one of those
things where drinking wise I was just
like oh [ __ ]
I'm really [ __ ] good at this yeah and
then I would just drink I'm good at this
bad thing many good at especially when
your dad died of cirrhosis at 48 he's
like oh this is how old we get the
cheese 14:48 so I watched it I was like
I have a joke right now on stage where I
was like a third generation alcoholic
which is too much pressure I felt like
ken griffey I felt like ken griffey the
third it's in your family my alt my dad
my dad's dad his all clocking out Wow
all clocking out cuz and you still went
down that path I was good at it dude
it's crazy when you're good at something
it's like what I want tomorrow you can
handle you could drink and then drink in
the morning one of those people man I
could I can't do the Bert which is like
wake up and be fine it started taking
its toll my late 20s where I started
waking up and I was like out of
commission for talked to mark Normand
about touring with Bert I used to hear
dude I saw mark Normand when we did
something is burning in New York right
when they came off and I saw Norman and
he goes he brought me like that's the
first thing he said me and I used to
drink with Norman so I knew Norman was
part of our drinking crew because it was
when I when I drank in New York it was
me Joe list Nate bargatze
and like a couple other people but Joe
list and a par get see were the guys
that we would drink every night [ __ ]
naked drank two naked
red-state Nate [ __ ] run up on eight
he could put him away
that's what Kurt Masur you guys are you
guys are all [ __ ] so right now Joe
list quit first six months later I'm
like yo dude you can quit and he's like
in a very jealous way he's like it makes
your life so much better and I was like
and I've been trying to quit
yeah and then I quit and then and then
we got Nate we're like dude Nate you got
to quit and now he's like it's the past
man quit huh yeah and it's like I still
smell
yes to a mark still dreams yeah Norman
drinks but he's the last of the Mohicans
he's the last one of our [ __ ] burly
guys are great comedians and Sam Morril
drinks too but Sam I thought you liked
it was a thing where that was part of
the celebration of doing shitty shows I
just go bomb on a bar show and then be
out drinking till 4:00 in the morning
and you say it's the best it was the
best well I mean I
yeah up their squad with like you would
Schultz doesn't really hang out with you
guys does he I mean we all came up
together came up that's not like part of
your crew it's like you I mean I think
it Sam yeah it was like Morril mark
Normand but I I hung with Nate list
Norman you know like che Wolff all those
guys around being around comedy like
that yeah coming up there were there was
the comedy store buy some I used to be
just [ __ ] Otakon but it was so much
fun we had no money we're taking these
weird gigs I remember we did a benefit
for a firehouse in Massachusetts because
Joe's uncle Dale works there and we went
up there and it was at Providence comedy
connection there was a Thursday night
our buddy Tom Dustin was headlining and
Tom Dustin's like our shows on Friday
and he's like you guys come through
Providence won't drink so we're like yes
absolutely
so we show up well drink and he's like
you guys want to do guest sets and the
show was like the emcee me Jola Snape
argh at sea like a full show and then
they have a dirty show after right and I
checked my phone and I'm like oh you
know big J is that catcher izing star at
the casino
so then big J comes through with Dave
Smith and Clem sock you know and just
The Late Show is like all ask in walked
off and y'all in the room and no one in
that room realized like you guys you're
not gonna see this lineup now this is
just like a thing that kind of working
on and you guys are all kind of blown up
together too
it's been a it's been it's been fun I
mean like something that Schulz brings
up that's that's a real good point is
Los Angeles you guys are much more
supportive of each other you guys lift
each other up a lot more and I think New
York used to have this kind of like
toxic competitiveness which was good for
us to a certain point but now we're all
kind of seeing like it's very New York
yeah
it's like what are you doing like you're
doing that one alright [ __ ] yeah yeah
it's more about its box it's more of
like a jealousy hater thing felt like in
New York but I would say here I think
most communes would say this out here I
think a lot of that like help each other
out came from Rogan yeah you have this
guy who yeah he's having these guys open
for more he's having on the podcast he's
encouraged people went pop yeah he did
have we do have that cuz we had that
with Colin Quinn and Bobby Kelly ANATEL
like a tell would take like just young
killers on the road and that was
something that like me when I started
headlining I always wanted to emulate I
was like man having a feature that
really makes you nervous yeah watching
them grow and get better
yes but legit Tim Dylan featured for me
for all four along for a while and it
was like one of those things where I was
like all right dude all right
and then Shane Gillis was on the road
enjoyed two years and he's such a beast
that you're like shut the [ __ ] up dude
shut the [ __ ] up like he's killing a
monster stop dewdrop but then you go on
dude I can tell you I'm gonna tell you
know better I know which sets in which
clubs on which shows I felt like my
features were like halfway through my
said I want to be like a show in Vermont
at the Vermont comedy club Tim Dylan
featuring for me and half way through my
set I just want to be like him come up
here take this kid dad he's 27 but
Maalik be yeah I'm telling you right now
I watch him like he's only been doing
stand-up for two years but he's got that
crazy discipline where he just writes
and works all the time and I'm watching
him and I'm like and I he's just
undeniable yeah I'm literally going I'm
watching his his ability to like his
timing his construction of jokes and I'm
like oh you're gonna be a [ __ ]
monster no I mean and they're people I
can he's a black kid from Louisiana I
put him up in just a room full of
rednecks from Tampa and they're just
like because he can he can cross every
line his jokes are undeniable and it's
it's only two years in I can't [ __ ]
imagine 25 years at that kind of it to
watch young talent know I've had nights
like in
you were Derek post is my feature yeah
commie store door get monster well I
don't want to go out yeah I'm like oh no
you really have that stand ovations I'm
like it for you like you have another 31
I'll just kind of mmm I'll do a Q&A when
I come out there are times there really
are times you're just like and I think
that's such a good thing for a comedian
because it's it's the thing I try to
explain to people out stand up is it's
constantly humbling you cannot not be
humbled and I always liked when like I
open for Bobby Kelly for a long time and
Bobby's get bobbies all more SOB Bobby
Kelly is Bobby Kelly is every bit I mean
if you if you ask Bill burr about Bobby
Kelly if you ask Bobby Bobby Kelly
killer yeah is right there with
everybody
dude he's super everybody can understand
the worst one in the past year I came
back so I did Edinburgh Fringe Festival
I did the Fringe Festival to work this
hour and I came back with this hour like
wait till they see this you're feeling
good wait till they see this [ __ ] out
I got it tight there's no air in there I
went out to Vegas for like a for a
comics bachelor party and I was like you
know what just to make my money back
I'll work the cellar Vegas at the Rio
Friday and Saturday
Bobby is getting ready for his Netflix
DeGeneres which drops December 31st on
Netflix the generate season 2 so Bobby's
doing a 15-minute set that he's getting
ready to tape three days later is it 15
minutes or 30 minutes from the 15 for
season two of degenerates [ __ ] Liz
who I love to death who runs the cellar
she runs like operate she's operations
manager for the seller puts me behind
Bobby on these shows I don't think I've
ever been like defeated before I've gone
up like that like I'm in the back of the
room like [ __ ] are you doing your hour
I'm just don't you only doing 15 doing
15 and at one point I go I gotta [ __ ]
follow Bobby about it gets thick you
want to go do you want me you want me to
go after you and I'm like no no progress
know what that is yeah yeah then I'm
just on stage and use your hearing
people chatter yeah
he's a month yeah Bobby
Bobby's been doing stand-up for 30 years
Bobby's like the closest I've ever had
to an older brother and he was a guy he
was a guy where the first time he told
me like he was nervous that I was making
him nervous that was like that swelled
my heart to like that but he would do it
in a Bobby way yeah yeah you could
[ __ ] kill 4:30 but can you do it for
a [ __ ] hour you know and I'm like you
said it'd kill 4:30 ok thanks I got
killed and then I remember I started
headlining and I was at Sanford & Sons
in Kansas City and they had it was
outside of Kansas who's in this like it
was in the legends shopping mall so it's
just like this mall Club and it was like
middle of July and walked through a hot
parking lot in Kansas City and I called
Bobby and I'm like this sock some
[ __ ] bomb and every night and I say
Bobby go
you wanted it be a [ __ ] headliner and
I was just like oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] this is
how it happens but yeah who's just like
one of those guys you know he's in that
Boston group that moved to New York
Rose patrice bird ain't cook al del bene
Marley in him all [ __ ] migrated yes
whoo New York and that's kind of Lawson
as it gets and Boston suffers no fools
Boston when you get up on stage it's
it's very different especially back when
they went yeah because the internet
wasn't strong so there was Boston
sensibility that then there was New York
sensibility it was so different than a
license but you couldn't do a set from
LA and bring it to New York or Boston
good [ __ ] really where do people be like
[ __ ] LA was just like yeah we love it
whatever they'd go to New York
you never saw LA comedians go to New
York you didn't see that happen your
guys when you were crushing in Boston
you were you came down to New York but
you could handle me there's a great
thought Lawson would be like this boss
and be like you Rogen we talked about
all the time you'd have working-class -
it's being like I don't give a [ __ ] what
are you saying about this and that make
me laugh cuz I work for a living you
piece of [ __ ]
there's a great documentary called when
stand-up stood out it's about the Boston
scene in the late 70s early 80s and call
it on it was a didn't that Bill Hicks
and that isn't that where Denis Leary
and all those I think it was like Leary
but it was also like
it's [ __ ] phenomenal but Colin Quinn
tells a story on when stand-up stood out
that's one of my favorite things about
worth they announced that he was from
New York and everyone in Boston was like
Steven right
that's Larry Stephen right Denis Leary
honk when that Goldthwait Lenny Clarke
Lenny Clarke Scott's great stories in
there but like Colin Quinn story about
him bomb bombing in Boston is exactly
what you said where they were like hey
our next guys from New York and everyone
was like what yeah then he just went up
there
Rock you [ __ ] Yankee oh the Mets and
my favorite thing is in the in the
documentary he says the next night he
gets up and kills and there's these two
guys sitting there like looking at him
like this and he like points or whatever
and they go we were here last night and
he's like ah they will [ __ ] don't [ __ ]
with you oh yeah Boston was a place I
was real lucky to get in with with Joe
list and a lot of Boston comedians that
when I was an open mic ER in New York
they'd be like none or not come up open
for me at Nix Nix Nix comedy stop in
Boston which becomes a dance club at
9:30 so they stopped the show yeah but
it's like this deep ground and it's not
the Knicks that these guys came up at
but it's still missed so now the
Internet's changed so much of this
because you can curate your own audience
yeah no you by the time you get out
there back in the day you got up in
front of a bunch people they didn't know
you were care about you and it was like
your jokes at me I got I remember
bombing and [ __ ] Caroline yeah where
the guy threw a straw at me it's the
only time I was like I was gonna kick
him the face I said yeah but but i but I
kind of deserved it because I was trying
to be funny and I was green and I yeah
they have it they well think the owner
said the club owner was like he's green
he's not ready for this club that's my
manager he was right yeah he was right
that's that's kind of the the best part
not starting out in a scene like that is
like you're going up and people like I
don't know who the [ __ ] you are so do
the job
and you're saying get on Penguin's oh
[ __ ] [ __ ] I just remember be I remember
bombing at that same catch rising star
it was a Nichols Casino and Providence
yeah and I headlined a weekend there and
I took such a beating and the feature
was doing like hey that mic stands big
black dick murder it murdering I mean I
thought these people were gonna [ __ ]
name their kids after this -
good guy and I started calling
Providence dumb Boston because I got mad
I was like [ __ ] you you guys are just
dumb Boston in their bag Robbins is all
mafia strong still crazy I remember two
weekends to eat and [ __ ]
like on that kind of on that kind of tip
if they don't know you and in Providence
Rhode Island and then there was a
Ticketmaster write-up it's one of my
first reviews and they said the feature
or the opener was hilarious
dais odor was just not funny he checked
his watch 20 times in 30 minutes and
also lucky lady I did 45 I did my
contractual obligation it said he
checked his watch 20 times in 30 minutes
no one laughed it was sad I was like get
to quit comedy that'll be like do you
know do you know the you know when they
talk about greatest running backs and
all that and they never mention OJ
Simpson cause he's a murderer yeah but
okay Simpson was was one of the cause be
no other unit correlate no you know who
you know who I remember I told enough to
I came up with all these guys bill burr
Kelly I saw all of them you know who did
puts everybody to shame you know
destroyed everybody if you as far as
killing you know what killed harder than
anybody I've ever seen in my [ __ ]
Rogan Joe robe yep yeah there was no one
like just [ __ ] so you have no idea
yeah well before he was doing the
observational stuff before he started
smoking weed he was to get Hughes to get
out there and do like two tigers [ __ ]
and things like that bro I'm telling you
there it's an objective fact that
consistently over a 10-year period heat
there was no one who would kill like
children just [ __ ] kill there was no
one and he would come off stage he
drenched in sweat each other then I Joe
briefly with Ari wants at the store like
I was in town he was he he was the
monster of all monsters so and and
competitive about it if you [ __ ] with
him he but I follow me one time so
follow me he'd go he'd be like I'm gonna
suck all the odds you know who doesn't
get credit for that anymore because he's
kind of became a thing of like but Dane
Cook oh well yeah when Joe list you
stick kill no but when Joe list you
where Joe list talked about coming up at
the
any connection in Boston he was like you
don't understand I know because I was
there yeah John and you know would tell
me stories about Dane wearing a Boston
Bruins jersey walking on tables doing a
dinosaur and he'd be like no one wanted
to even dude I I was there I saw it yeah
one of the reasons I got back in the
comedy yeah was watching that
[ __ ] people hating la they not
dangerous answer is is undeniable
everyone copies his style now but also
you don't know how big Dane was at the
time on any of his issues whenever you
treat people like [ __ ] when he's at the
very top and he's apologized right now
but so he's not passed at the store but
they put him on like certain shows in
the main room and if you have to follow
him good luck dude I'll never forget
this there's these two hot girls won't
giant titties kept harassing all the
comics like no one could figure it out
shut the [ __ ] up and someone goes in the
back and like do these [ __ ] chick to
the front and dingos where they at he
was right we walk out 13 we go right he
goes I'll take care of it yeah and I
don't know Dame at all he's always been
super nice very very like Dane I've
always liked her he goes out there man
and he just starts doing and they don't
pop me goes yeah dude
he always only supposed to 15 minutes
thirty minutes is just like killing the
entire room people on the ground I've
never seen anything like it yeah I went
that's just all off the top of the dome
if you want to doing it and he comes in
the back if this family goes that should
do it
yeah holy dude the greatest sniper of
all time is Dave Attell Dave Attell I
got disarmed people oh my god I wasn't
even there for this but this story has
made the rounds at the cell a pound for
pound it tells probably that he's the
best I was [ __ ] with him in New York
one time she's being such an [ __ ] and
he goes ma'am do you have kids and she
goes no and he goes then you're a
failure these two there's is that the
cellar and there's these two spanic
women in the front row not giving
anybody anything yeah and that wrote
that front wrote the cellar there you're
on them you're up there you're looking
right at it right there giving them to
give it nobody nothing
silent Oh
angry faced people get off like these
[ __ ] women dude no one [ __ ]
couldn't crack Mattel goes up [ __ ]
jacket on hood on grabs the mic you know
he goes ladies what's wrong did Selena
die again and everyone's like he just
comes in [ __ ] tears it's just like
it's so [ __ ] oh he's still wearing
that jacket hoodie I was just with him
this way he's the best just hanging out
with mouse Yoda do go that was in New
York he's to stay at the same hotel and
I saw him outside in his hood and I I
was scared to say anything yeah I
swapped my he dude is after the Boston
bombing and Boston or whatever I was
outside still smoking cigarettes and I'm
outside smoking and Dave just comes out
of youse hey damn and he lights up
cigarette he goes how many Boston
bombing jokes do you have this is maybe
two days after I go none and he goes no
seriously how many do you have I go none
and he goes uh and just walks away just
[ __ ] six yeah like six Boston you
know tells the best manner I've ever
seen yeah it's it's [ __ ] like you
watch him in a guy like him and Colin
Quinn are always the guys were I will I
will amend my schedule to watch that huh
you know what I mean if I'm like if I
can go downstairs and I never want to
make eye contact with them so I sit on
that stairwell at the cellar and I'll
just sit and look at the ground like a
weirdo and just listen to him through
the door good gosh damn you're just
seeing [ __ ] 35 years of like well
he's always making that way in LA on eat
burgers but it tell us great name I tell
was great 25 years ago yeah I tell was
that justice guy I mean I'm not kidding
there's a great picture okay him you
could tell it's drunk Dave it's on the
stairwell of the cellar if you walk up
it's on the left side some of my
favorite pictures and it's taken like
from someone kneeled down and took a
picture with the two-drink minimum thing
but he's sitting on stage with a
cigarette and he's got a beer and he's
doing like a real like a tell face and
you're like man I miss drinking it I've
never got to see drinking at all and I
moved to New York right so where Yankee
quit like oh seven I think and he's like
he's just the greatest of all time like
skanks for the memories is skanks it's
one of the greatest comedy game you
special son of a Gary yeah coming out
Saturday on HBO this Saturday to
Saturday oh you know what's the big deal
y'all got the whole the old school intro
from 1983 I asked for it they were like
yeah we'll give it school so it's like
would you shoot it at Bowery Ballroom in
New York hour
yeah it's [ __ ] nuts dude it was it's
fun like cheers I've been building it I
did the Netflix I did Netflix the
stand-ups I think we taped that like
March of 2017 so yeah I mean it was cool
[ __ ] how many people about 400 yeah it
was great man I did I I saw the size of
it and the way they lit it in the way
it's directed by Chris store and like
you know working with their whole group
of Jerrod Carmichael and and Bo Burnham
they kind of and with HBO they work with
those guys a little both of [ __ ] man and
the conversations we had raised like
what do you want for this special and I
was like dude I want to strip down
old-school HBO special like let me go do
the work on the material do you know Bo
uh yeah I'm and so Boeing fan is do Bo
and I we didn't know each other well but
through working together we had lunch a
couple times and talked about this and
he's like a guy where it was man when
you make something with somebody where
you know they're at the they're at the
top and they're gonna give you that room
to do whatever the [ __ ] you want cuz
it's not like did you did you uh
briefing about putting on like netflix
or showtime right like how did HBO come
on it really was one of those things
where I talked to my agent I was like I
feel like as a straight generic-looking
white dude
I'll get buried on Netflix they'll put
me out on Netflix and then I'll just you
know you just I'll be up there for the
front you know and I was like I wanted
to HBO and she was like you know let me
talk to HBO and and Nina at HBO had
heard of me and we put it together where
I was headlining the seller was doing
like headlining sets on Tuesdays where
you could do an hour and I was like I
get one of those headlining sets HBO
came out this last December
HBO came out watched it and then like
you know two days later was like let's
do it let's do an hour and 29 th don't
I didn't believe it man I didn't believe
I was like for real is the contract
silent and they're like yeah and then
the great thing about HBO is is they're
like when do you want to do it and I
told him I was like let me do the
Edinburgh Fringe Festival I want to do
fringe and work the hour out and so then
I went to big J you know cuz we do the
bonfire that was the Fringe Festival
I've always wanted to do it I recommend
it for anyone getting ready for an hour
it's football camp just show up it's
miserable what sometimes just sometimes
you're like I was bombing in front of 15
people with this hour in a room that
fits 110 but then sometimes it was sold
out you know like this [ __ ] hour it's
cooking and sometimes you're like I
sucked but I just recorded every night
you take a walk Edinboro is gorgeous so
it's fun to walk around
I want to go fun it's it's a whole month
but you know doing we do the bonfire
four days a week and so I had to go to J
in January and be like listen dude is it
cool if I go do Fringe Festival I'm
gonna be gone for five weeks and big J
is the [ __ ] man and he was like yeah
dude he's the nicest guy he's the
funniest [ __ ] human being on the
planet do you two together I was telling
him when when I was with you guys doing
your show on Sirius yeah I was doing you
know promotion for my special on
Showtime and you guys were I don't know
like the fifth or sixth stop yeah I love
you guys was okay here's another
interview like my energy was low yeah
and then I had it's the funnest show
I've ever done you say oh thanks so
funny except I was laughing so hard dude
the whole thing about that show is is
like it's when people are like oh so you
have like a job doing a radio show you
like nah man I go smoke weed in the
afternoon and then hang out with Jay and
we just bring up YouTube clips and big
Jays so goddamn funny you guys together
yeah but thanks man Jay so funny so
funny and he's such a nice guy
yeah he's the best he's a real Mensch
like we did a show with them remember we
did the Orpheum Theatre in Phoenix so
good oh yeah you guys did the whole
thing's comedy I think it was re big Jay
yeah Brian feelin me man that's you know
who needs more credit for like bridging
everyone is Ari Shaffir okay
that like a guy he'd want to call me by
you ya ask me yeah I know it was I
called up and I'm like yeah whatever you
[ __ ] recommend dude Ari's the [ __ ]
man cuz he came out from LA it moved to
New York that's right and he was like
what you
he did it in such an re way of like
what's your guys's problem like you know
how he asked those questions are you
like I don't know what the [ __ ] he
talkin about he's like are you guys so
cocky why don't you guys friends with la
comics and then he kind of brought big J
out here to do this is not happening and
weren't and he started mixing everyone
together yeah and it kind of became a
thing where you're like man Ari's the
[ __ ] man he's a great dude I just
[ __ ] love that dude and all you guys
out in New York have been great but it's
been great to meet you guys and get to
know people you know on the west coast
that I think the Internet's helping but
it's great to see Schultz come over here
you know like you guys know else Mike
yeah yeah dude [ __ ] Holly you want to
talk about a guy that [ __ ] murders
Andrew shows he's well he's flip the
game you'll see tommix been doing it for
15 murders who were making millions
dollars I mean he's going up and just
doing crowd work and then posting it
I mean you talking about a guy who here
ago wasn't something that he doing well
he's always been doing well now he's
sold out Town Hall twice man he's the
guy's I mean you talking about changing
the game went hold up oh this is how you
this is how you sell take it yeah but
come on the comic peep this coming up
with Schulz it was always uh having
conversations with him you're always
like this guy [ __ ] he's so smart yeah he
really knows his [ __ ] dude and he was a
guy where um man I think we're kind of
cool place in comedy right now well
we're more supportive of each other than
we've ever been because I know why you
wouldn't be I've never looked at it as a
competition I've I mean I just
understood it at all you know I've never
been I'm not that way naturally but I've
never understood why you wouldn't help
everybody when you could I agree I've
always that's but that yeah
traditionally though comics aren't that
the worst
they're the worst yeah well what it is
is they're awful to each other but I
just never got involved in that [ __ ]
this uh actor David Costabile he plays
wags on billions and when he when we
first started working together on
billions he was like oh you're a
stand-up comedian and I was like yeah
he's like you're the you guys are the
meanest to each other
second only to Broadway dancers holy
[ __ ] Broadway sense rot away dancers
will [ __ ] push each other over he's
like comics he'll be like this guy's
funny and you're like yeah he's alright
yeah billions I just I play an ass I
just played idiot name a fee that that's
one of the reasons I stopped doing last
I was doing a bunch of open mikes just
like that's where that shit's like put I
would do the open mics I get the
Icehouse and Woodland Hills and all over
but when I get there it was just other
comedians who were just waiting to go on
there's sitting this yeah like oh it's
just a bunch of haters so when I started
it gives you on about enough that or
something they're saying yeah nothing's
worse than improv oh it's so strange
didn't work you're doing improv like a
TV show like mad TV or any [ __ ] night
you have it was in laugh at when people
say comics I mean I [ __ ] laugh try
try it Center nightlife Second City
MADtv try clock being around those
[ __ ] who are first of all
really good but the biggest comedy snobs
of all time and oh by the way when
you're pitching your idea in a writers
room and they're talking behind your
back yeah I physically threaten people I
bet oh I can't I can't imagine they're
so mean let me watch you so mean to
everybody everybody would be so mean I
was just like I just don't come from
that I'm just different watching uh you
know be a good friends with with Shane
Gillis and knowing how [ __ ] funny he
is
yeah when he got SNL I was about to be
like if he would have kept that job
someone from Harvard would have gotten a
job broken because he's a he's a
Mechanicsburg Pennsylvania like I'm
funny because that's who I am as a
person
well would you take on that it's [ __ ]
outrages that cottage it's a cottage
industry right now what I think they
took out they took a character he did on
a podcast completely out of context it
made it look like that little riff
anthem is who he is as a person tennis
its context its you can change context
now with the internet but bums me out
those these corporations including SNL
should know better it's like guys just
just he can say sorry it was insensitive
comment I'm if you go but I just but you
know this yeah hominis knows Hugh but if
you went back to listen to all the [ __ ]
we've done pocket you went all the way
back stuff I've said in Krabi ed no one
have a job for a Night Live it's like
hold up you guys need someone like Shane
like how does ladies aren't good comic
he's one of the fighter yes there's
there's no doubt in my mind that if he
would have gotten the proper shot there
would have done he's gonna do amazing
[ __ ] that's the great thing about
comedies you can take elves and still
well I will say it but this is a problem
I do have a lot of comics are saying
he's better off without it
hold on no no you're not whoa he's gonna
be okay mark brink well Brian knows more
than any day Night Live yeah but it's a
big [ __ ] deal but let me tell you why
then it sounds take it on the road
because in a way it immediately means
you're selling tickets on the road and
that's the dangerous part I think with
essen I've watched it I watch it with
che and I wash it's different you know
why cuz they put the little pieces you
put it on yeah cuz they cuz could not
get so the the clubs can use it yeah but
I'm saying if you stay on s it's not
like a podcast it's it's a steroid it's
a it's an anabolic steroid it's or if
you get on will you get on SNL and
they're like here's a [ __ ] fan base
now that you go to a movies it yeah
Lawrence just you working for the
dot-com you can if you're if you're good
about it you can you can desert its
changing know certain people sell
tickets on them yeah yeah for sure but
I'm saying if you yeah if you stay if
you stay I think it's one of those
things where I can't imagine the
competitiveness of a MADtv of a [ __ ]
I'm not sound that life though I live
when you it's live and you have that the
for David I know I know I've known
through the years many people very well
I work with one out Jim Tim Meadows yeah
but I know that I know the inner
machinations of what that's like I've
just I've I've gotten all the details
from people everybody from Amy Poehler
to default to to Spain when they talk
about their Kevin pressure-cooker like
Adam sales like dude though it's what
makes comes across it makes you great oh
for sure cuz I think it I think it
forges you and do it right comedian I
mean also it also ages you like being
the president the light yeah man for
real
I pray on my sides I ice cream tested in
2014 it got close and I was always like
oh man what if like I should and now I
realize like that [ __ ] would I would
have been drinking again I would have
been [ __ ] yeah but yeah I'm not the
kind of guy that is like Lauren being
like I don't know maybe not this week
why what did I [ __ ] do wrong wait you
said I'd be like remember is that this
is a very long career yeah and and you
know all you can do is get really good
at what you do and if you get really
good at what you do and be kind cuz
stand-up is relentless it's ruthless oh
great special now you got to start all
over again
oh that's why I'm out right now we're
people you just can't it's gonna drop
Saturday and I know for a [ __ ] fact
I'm gonna go to tweet next week that's
like when's the next one
my answer is sucker I write I have to
write no matter what a happy hour right
do you read the comments though cuz
you're gonna get people to like know
that look it's uh I turned I turned I
took Twitter off my phone in October of
2018 why cuz I it was ruining great
experiences I would be out at this
[ __ ] I would be at a concert like we
wouldn't saw war on drugs me and big J
so our war on drugs at terminal 5 having
this unbelievable job smoked a joint
[ __ ] love them they're a great band I
look at my phone and it's like [ __ ]
god never made me laugh and then I'm
like who the [ __ ] are you [ __ ] and I'm
going to this guy's tweets well this
guy's tweets and it's a band that I love
is playing a Mikey [ __ ] [ __ ]
and I'm like oh never done that one time
oh it's not one that's a you're good at
hobby once a Joel derby yeah I I just
rollers too but I've always got I know
for the season I also know from acting
that so I learned this from reviews so
reading reviews if you do a flag you've
always told me not that yeah if you do a
play you get yeah I would get seven
great reviews and then there'd be the
one comment and I was like and I
remember that this is exactly what my
acting teacher said he said that one
comment will [ __ ] haunt you don't
listen or read anything including and
especially good but now it's good will
define you yeah I don't want to [ __ ]
hear it I know what we're doing I do my
work do you work but here's one of the
reasons why I only now at like I'll post
and I delete the app Instagram I don't
have my phone smart I don't have
Instagram during the week then why go on
the road I post like pitch my food or
whatever my friends are here
shows then Sunday I get on plane I
delete the app because here's the
problem people go because the negativity
both the positive
you're like off on the next Kevin Hart
yeah I don't need to work that I'm good
too it's relaxes you because I get you
know it's 90 maybe 10 90 people are
great then the 10 bad but either way
it's not gonna like the great never had
that like Chappelle's the hardly and
they like me they really like have
social media yeah all we did is we just
here we would just you go out here's the
out it's just like college I don't know
you don't notice the 7 8 people that
don't like you also you remember the
bombs more than you remember the kill
always you remember the bombs were your
life of human Antonio San Antonio that
weekend I spent at [ __ ] the River
Center comedy club haunts me in a way
around like I remember eating [ __ ] every
night yeah to finally on the sunday show
I snapped at the audience and I was like
you want to know how I know you guys
don't have good taste because you
vacation in San Antonio and one guy just
goes hey great comeback that's so funny
but even burr was saying when it's
special which is paper tigers one of the
best of him in last 10 years yeah it
sticks and stones a paper tiger back to
back it's like it's a [ __ ] fail I
told burr you maybe want to quit it's so
gorgeous like it's so good but so
knowing how good specialist he was
saying I forget what podcast he was on
maybe it's his and he was like yeah you
know I got on Instagram I was like you
know what I know it's a good special I'm
just gonna get on there and read a few
comes to us and I get six deep and it's
like [ __ ] yeah dude it's so funny you
said that because I know on Saturday my
girlfriend's like what do you want to do
on Saturday I'm terrible at celebrating
myself I don't worry I'd rather do the
work my girlfriend's like what do you
want to on Saturday your HBO specials
coming up you say move on get my own
place yeah I was like did you stop
bugging me no I said I was like I
honestly I want to get dinner in Queens
I want a smoke a joint and I want to
watch the Irishman with you and just
hang out what and she was like she was
like let's do that lets just play Mario
Kart let's just [ __ ] let's just hang
out and height and I'm like you know
what
want to watch the intro because I want
to see the Shh and then like the actual
apol yeah the second I hit the stage
networks Irish River yes sir but it it's
it is one of those things where you the
negative always outweighs the positive
the way we're wired and it's it's I
can't stand anything I do yeah I can't
stand anything stops cos it's no work I
had you know what I did and I recommend
this for all comedians next time you're
editing a special they sent me the audio
first and I listened to the audio they
edited it and then I was kind of like
alright this joke should be a little
different and then when I went into the
editing Bay to watch it I was kind of
like I knew how the set went so I was
like alright I kind of want to see this
but dude it's if Bill burr is feeling
that there's no one that's gonna be safe
and calm be such a long game why why
blow yourself well you just keep doing
it yeah keep writing it's what Picasso
said he just kept painting well you an
exhibit he was killing you should you
should be worried if he show up for
showing there's no in the crowd that was
most of my mob scene now it's self
promotion regardless if there's noble if
there's no crowd there then it's like oh
maybe you don't really culturally if
you're Irish yeah yeah you're raised to
be you're raised like any of that [ __ ]
is I grew up in the house my mom was
like who the [ __ ] do you think you are
that's why be like no one are you sure
that's right god damn right that's right
now you have to go hey come see me I'm
amazing well I had such a he he helped
me yeah I do in Roman were the ones
because I I had such I was allergic yeah
to anything I was like I can't do this I
didn't know you know and but you know
you learned by the way translates to
butts in the seats you must do it I
still don't do it well I still don't do
it well enough because here's the thing
about Brian Brian has more talent than
any comics we know any guy you listed
has more talent than all of us and as
soon as these people get to know counts
he said you're talking you're talking
arena it's like that's where he should
be asking me and Whitney were talking
about like everyone knows how good
talent so it's like if you just be a
little better at the self-promotion yeah
I'm gonna sit down that's my next thing
I was thinking about because I've to
lazy yeah that's that's the gotta do it
that's the talent is overrated part
that's your apply practice is end by the
way same for me I don't [ __ ] I'm just
kind of like I don't know the work
speaks for itself
like now [ __ ] because no one knows
how to do wasn't work yeah because
there's there's too much Judas too much
when I saw your so I think you posted
her at someone posted you get the HBO
specials like oh [ __ ] yeah yeah dude it
was that was that was fun man that was
like a cool thing where I was sitting on
I'm so yeah because I obviously I feel
like I look up to because we're from the
same hometown is a piece of a comic and
it's like when I was in Denver doing
economy works I was doing all the press
around there yeah we're talking about
Denver comics I'm like well there's TJ
Miller yeah and then there's Dan Soder
yeah I'm coming up the way yeah that's
all we got I do read there's a good
[ __ ] group you also got I remember
the old dogs that came out of oh I'm out
Roseanne Tim Allen Tim Allen yeah bad
Sinbad I didn't know Simbel was Denver
Sinbad's damn Oh cholera guys his friend
it's a [ __ ] Rocky Mountain boy I mean
they're old and ya know Sinbad walking
murdered murders go watched until deaths
if you think he lost any of his fastball
go watch Sinbad slap the dick off an
audience unbelievable I walked into
Caroline's one time someone was like you
know CID meds in town and I was like I
think I was going to like see I was
leaving serious and like you know
Sinbad's at Caroline's I was like cuz I
walk downstairs I was like oh oh you
like heard it in the lobby okay what the
[ __ ] is happening in there I know went
to the back and went around and watched
I was like this guy's unbelief you know
who else to do it mr. Cooper hangin mr.
Cooper you know our mark and didn't have
didn't have any materials cos just throw
out stuff I love our current dude yeah
oh my god I think there's like I think
that happened 25 years mark is always
mark hurry yeah mark I think mr. Cooper
I think think like because like with
Dane I remember I went to like this
second Patrice benefit which burp what's
on for you know Patrice's family and he
books like a tell de pollo like all the
commas another one how crazy small those
I don't know it's I love him it's like
all these guys were you're just like
watching these killers and Dane Cook was
on it just you know Dane came up in
Boston and I
the last show that I bought a ticket for
and sat in the audience no no because I
was like I want to watch this I want to
watch this lineup big J went second it
murdered and then I watched Dane and he
hit me hard like four times rather yeah
and you know you don't laugh and now as
a comedian you're like oh that's funny
yeah that's funny there was like four
Dane Cook jokes I was like oh [ __ ]
that's great he's such a baby yeah I can
how long he's been doing it because of
whatever the public's kind of paint him
in now yeah he's setting off seasons
games ridiculous but whatever yeah but
you know funny
you really do you watch like I still
love going down and like if burrs in
town like sneaking to the side because
you guys see per all the time but when
burr comes in New York it's a [ __ ]
treat yeah you're like oh [ __ ] bill
burrs and then I like when our guys come
out of here like when Bobby Kelley's
like I [ __ ] found a lie just [ __ ]
rearrange um Bobby yeah because he's
just it's just like that's the thing I
love the most about comedy is just the
community of comedy well it's such a if
you think about how what a small
fraternity it is yeah it's very
difficult it's a very difficult skill to
do to be aloft and so very few people
like there are some great actors out
there I'm cool but you know they can't
do this very few people can stand-up is
terrifying the most people yeah if you
had talked to most people they're like
they're it's it's the scariest thing
ever for them it is because they're like
reaching a deal with enemy fighter
German you talk to any fighters not any
big nose both you [ __ ] got in there
well he's just fearless Leslie I'm
saying there's nothing more terrifying
the thought of steep meö touch being on
the other side or you know God he's to
fight Eustace tomorrow the steep a - I
mean by the way steep a was on billions
I got to work with him for like two days
and I'm like you're the [ __ ] greatest
human Deontay Wilder
we're on sets right there both on
billion they were both on an episode of
billions and I just had to being like
these humble warriors yeah you talked to
Deonte it was him and his boy that was
there like his manager just sat there
and guys when I was like hey man you're
gonna fight Tyson Fury is like yeah man
I'm hoping so I'm hoping just so nice
you know then you get out of his element
but then you watch him just beat the
[ __ ]
like that right hand he's dead oh yeah
that picture all the way to the left
he's done like me steep a and Deonte and
Kelly that was like such a crazy day
just to be this way that's that's that's
water on the far left yeah it's Kelly
aucoin who plays dollar bill and then
the guy in the middle is Matt by Monty
unbelievable boxing trainer that's
worked with like razor ruddock and a
bunch of people and he was the one that
coordinated the fight they did the rat
from that yeah the ref and then you're
just in there and you're like that's
fearless to me so it's funny when you're
like yeah I'm just you know he's done
both you know he went from pro football
to he said I'm not working out and he's
like he goes I guess I'll fight so he
has he goes he wins Golden Gloves then
he goes to tough his knees [ __ ] I
remember Tom basically he he fights he
fights he loses in the finals to [ __ ]
well I remember that fight dude I was a
champion yeah and then he decides and
then he's fighting and then we start
doing a podcast and then this
[ __ ] says I wanted to stand up
yeah so so I'm like Jesus what I was
like huh my voice got high used to choke
my first job this maniac this maniac we
were doing Seattle and there were 1200
people in the house I'm 12 now think
about this you've never done stand it
ready those were my open lines and I
said to him I go I go I feel how
craziest thing about this he's never
done Santa and he's never performed he's
never studied performing yeah they look
at God like crystal has been doing
performance since middle school and
doing musicals yeah all of us I've been
doing it since you know everybody you
can't discount that amount of experience
sure he majored in sports
now he's gonna he's fighting in his
underwear yeah and now he's gonna get up
and follow much people and try to be
funny
hey in front of 1,200 people alone no
net and I would say it oh my go just go
tell a story tell a story you know the
story to tell just tell the story you
got a couple of them and he would go out
he do his breathing exercises seem like
still [ __ ] I'm like I guess he did when
he was fighting and then he will just go
out and do it totally fearless and do it
over
he's saying 1200 people now and I'm 15
years in the weave my special you said
that my nuts just coming I was like you
know what else how he's actually
completely feeling it's like he where
there was a horse the huge horse at a
big stunt horse not a pony horse and we
had there was a funny thing where if we
could just fall off the horse we needed
some stuntmen to fall off the ladder
cute 3d at a gallop yeah so Brennan goes
to me goes let's just do it
oh my go what he's never gone on horse
there's some girls getting a horse
together and we'll just fall off on her
I've ridden horses since I was a kid
oh so you knew I'm not a good horseback
rider yeah I've ridden horses I was a
kid because my mom used to make me so I
got a glitch yeah it's very dangerous
yeah and he goes well it's either
fearlessness or its being stupid I mean
yeah both but I mean what I mean is that
that you're the one thing that yeah
they're baby bird say ever that you are
not the gutsiest [ __ ] you think without
sports you would have gone into the
military do you think there's like
nothing a question you'd think you would
have gone to Marines or army unlike that
maple falls not all my family military
so you had a military family yeah cuz I
kind of think I think of soldiers like
that man like these soldiers guys
they're like you come back and like the
humility they have or you're like I
never told you this story about Goldberg
Bill Goldberg I mean play played pro
football yeah Lana Falcons they came in
I 100 and zero and WCW I mean you know
wrestling face okay did I tell you like
wrestling connect on did I tell you
story off air no I build plays my
brother in school then and the Gophers
and no problem he's he's 52
bills my edge comes from here do this oh
he's he's he's boy when you look at his
hand he's built like a steam Vegas
finger yeah and he's got the biggest
neck but he played pro football he's a
little bit athlete was a D lineman
he's ridiculous d tackle and well there
is and so we're the same as you can see
how much bigger it is but either way
he's very red very red so but either way
we do this thing where he has to come
through the line he has
peow three-point stance and two stunt
men come out and he has to lay them out
and then he goes to me I'm gonna come at
you very that's a good classic he was
I'm gonna come at you I'm gonna die for
your head you have to duck out of the
way and I can set this offset yeah he
goes I'm coming for you so make sure you
duck cuz for Bill there's bill has two
gears zero and [ __ ] let's [ __ ] go
yeah apart the end so he goes I'm gonna
I'm coming for your head so make sure
you [ __ ] duck cuz for him he's gonna
make it real I these two stuntmen were
big strong martial arts guys yeah they
were big dude he was key was coming off
that line of 52 and hitting them so hard
with his elbows that the sound was so
loud and they were going they were
flying yeah III I said I stopped
everything after the third one because
they were getting hurt and I go hey we
have to stop
I go bill you can't hit these guys this
hard I had to literally really yeah it
helped him out my larger point is there
another guys about the other girls hey
thanks Brian well dude they they were
getting my larger point is one of the
guys was a some kind of a special he was
like I mean yeah flash and I said to
Bill I go the way you were laying the
man he goes hey dude I was a pro
football player yeah I don't give a [ __ ]
what you were if there is a difference
between pro football that that kind of
level of athlete yeah and and it all due
respect to anybody in the military
really tough guys but it is a little bit
of a different thing for sure like it so
I feel like you you would have been just
fine
doing any oh you would rent SEAL Team
six maybe put a bullet in the [ __ ] he
did the Mythbusters thing where they
wanted to see if if a human being could
mimic what the weaponry carried by the
guy in what was the video and do shut up
mark yeah stepdad Nick for putting that
on our computers these are arming this
out and his [ __ ] look at his look at
how think he is you say so they they had
the creator of doom come in recreate the
actual level if it was for a human and
then they had like their guys do it then
they go there now we're gonna take
professor athlete see if we can actually
carry all that gear and kill the
monsters and beat the level
real level did you do it yep hell yeah I
[ __ ] did it did it and broke he'd he'd
proved he was like oh no human being can
do myth busted huh look at him barking
and you were fighting then right yeah I
was fighting then here's my thing look
at how much [ __ ] you have here's my
thing shot everyone in the dick
but dude wait amen I don't know why and
they know you know off here they went
you gotta quit shooting them in the dick
I'm gonna tell you this where are you
what time you what is that I don't know
but if you were a marine and you shot
everyone in the dick you'd be a you'd be
like a tail that villagers tell each
other in Afghanistan instead of the
Punisher yeah with the back there is it
there's a there's a guy for the United
States it's Cox meticulous he's stopping
the next generation of Afghani warriors
how much weight were you carrying I
don't know but it's so heavy and then
what did you have to do run an obstacle
course and then shoot the guys like you
scroll the far left on their chin no
down nowhere says fired right that's the
level oh my god it was cool exact ad -
created from doom there who they did the
level is so cool that was cool cuz my
dad's like the biggest Mythbusters fan
so that I promised at him and that guide
the the the dorky guide the guy with
them I the orange they just talked for
like science louis c.k yeah the guy who
looks like a human walrus yeah yeah he
goes mythbusted you come in front of a
young female comedian your career will
end that's a light yeah I was a light
that's [ __ ] you're a phaser boy do
much did you weigh there I'm pretty
heavier now that looks like 245 they're
like 250 no mark hi yes fine do their
job Buster's yeah but you're right a d1
football but like bill Goldberg's like I
played the NFL what do you want I'm
telling a Julio Joe here's the thing
last he was ill he failed he was
Goldberg wasn't [ __ ] in the NFL don't
get me wrong
yes great he'll play he wasn't like a
he'll tell you jr. say our like dirt
Thomas we're like a Bryant yo Carl
Mecklenburg
I can't because at 52 hours works not
fast it was and how hard it was and I
was like this think about this Mike I
got a scary thing about this Brock
Lesnar phenomenal athlete we all be fun
all out could- oh hold on practice squad
was I wasn't that because he didn't know
the game though excuse me wasn't good
enough but but but that also footballs a
lot of skill and know-how doesn't get
enough yeah yeah you just got it you
just gotta here's the thing about that
too he wore number 69 though that was
pretty bad that's sick any kind of fight
we gotta beat his ass but there was a
guy named Stephen Neal who only wrestled
in college football wrestler went oh
yeah good footwork the New England
Patriots went yeah you do drafted them
starting left tackle for the New England
Patriots for I don't know 10 years I
never played down a football Wow
collegiate wrestling I think sets people
up as far as athleticism goes because of
how [ __ ] hard they train it's so on
you were in the UFC all the wrestlers
that go to the UFC with that background
oh it sit there like look if you like
one battle getting restless
okay he's a [ __ ] blonde silverback so
for every bit he thinks he's a
silverback it's so crazy huh so crazy
here's the thing rag-dolled on the
Minnesota Vikings they beat the [ __ ] out
of him really a dude beat the [ __ ] out
that's gotta be just because it's skill
and technique they've been doing their
yeah technique I'd probably blame no
hold on and there's a champion here's
the other thing there's guys like a
bigger and stronger than him way bigger
and stronger come on it's the NFL dude
it's yeah you think about like I look
corrected two floors Buckner on the
Niners
six-foot-six 328th let ACCA's [ __ ]
people understand well just dominate you
like Nick Bosa
I'm a huge Niner fan Nick poster comes
in and they're like like he's not gonna
be that good
derman reading one article when the
foreign minister after him but they're
like if he stays healthy he could not
only win rookie Defensive Player of the
Year but could win Defensive Player of
the Year and I was like how good is a
stocky the first game it gets tampa bay
buccaneers he breaks through the
backfield and runs past Jameis Winston
that's how fast he was no man his
brother yeah and propellers and then his
daddy was a first-round draft pick his
uncle's prescribed his father wasn't got
I'm boss in Chicago didn't know that
that makes a mean cooler that's a card
Oh
Wow killed tats nope three guys with a
baseball bat
geez you want to know what happens with
your grandson he's a monster on the line
monster monster Louisville no you
haven't
speaking of mafia you haven't seen Irish
man yeah I'm wait I want it three times
bat the HCC you shot three times
is it that good I thought it's little
Sloan I loved it a cop smart oh yeah
baby I'll go he falls asleep
I'm just watching it yeah is it is it a
dude your last chance to use I'm sorry I
loved it don't listen to any anything
anybody says there is damn that was
their [ __ ] grandfather one of the
gunmen in the st. Valentine's Day
Massacre oh wow
crazy look Nick Bosa and the oddest
tidbit of the 2013 draft that's crazy
dude Becky own I come home and he's
always just watching mob documentary or
whatever now it's crazy it's [ __ ]
crazy I'll come home he watch all he
does is watch boxing interviews I call
them it is terrorist videos because
they're always liked on cellphones
they're like a different language you
know Gennady golovkin hot corner he's
loves boxing and it's all begun it's
like you still funny yeah I'm like what
the [ __ ] you watching dude and it's just
coming from a but I'm exactly the same
are you
I can show you my mind yeah it's all
about kickboxing which is which is
Russian it's a Russian web yeah but like
he's obsessed with that whole big bear
crew and like chocolatito yeah I'll be
watching I have a joke and the special
about strawweight boxers and their
translators because I've watched so much
boxing with Becky on but I'm like but
oxr he just I just loves yeah he's from
Youngstown so he's like a Mycenae guy Oh
Pigman yeah he's a big boom guy and so
it was like I got to take the only time
I've ever a new work with Showtime the
only time I've like ever flexed anything
was the porter Garcia fight Shawn Porter
ok Danny Garcia at Barclays and I was
kind of like to show time I was like hey
can I uh I get some tickets you know
no I yeah we'll get you some tickets and
they got me third row for that fight and
I got to take Becky own and he was like
he loved it but the coolest [ __ ] was
David Costabile who plays wags on
billions huge fight fan we always talk
boxing when I see him on you know
set together and I told him I was going
he's like you know what i'ma call
Showtime let me see if I can go you know
who loves wags on billions rappers and
fighters really he's the hawk because
he's the big dick energy oh I know that
he's the [ __ ] man yeah he's he's a
[ __ ] man but he came that
boxing match and it was so great to
watch people be like yeah like one of
the one of the twins why am I the
Charles winds it's like [ __ ] wags that
one Charl of phyto fight Saturday if I
say yeah which are excited about to get
his title back right yeah yeah it'll be
how long i watch that yeah but it was
like countless but going to dona fights
like that it was like ticking Becky on
he was like judicious and he'd like knew
everybody he's like Carol spends his
threes three seats down up front you
know [ __ ] smell that's cool yeah yeah he
got me back into boxing because I grew
up loving it yeah but then uh stop
watching it they live with Becky own and
you're like okay alright I watched all
these weird videos I listen to Paulie
Malignaggi just because he's the [ __ ] I
like so funny but like watching him
break down fights Vecchio de Becque you
wanna watch this YouTube video I don't
how deep in a hole are you dude I see I
don't think I don't go deep on fighting
I go deep on like after I watched Irish
man I went deep in the Jimmy Hoffa oh
yeah yeah you don't learn about him in
school no I knew he went missing and was
like he's a union leader and you look
you know he disappear it's insane it's
also crazy how many people took credit
for killing him a ton it was kind of
like the hey do they think pain this was
well this is based off a book called I
heard you painting houses where it's
from this guy the Irish man where a lot
of people think he's full of [ __ ] yeah
and actually there was a guy whose balls
deep in Jimmy Hart's kind of a ruin for
me because I read that people thought he
was full of [ __ ] so I had trouble but
yes and no but even the FBI is like well
he's eight on our list and as far as
suspects so they were suspecting him but
when you look at there's a guy who used
balls even Jimmy Hoffa came out with his
like book his official book yeah went up
to Robert De Niro during the press and
was like dude you [ __ ] us this guy's
full of [ __ ] this isn't the narrative
and you're glorifying this guy's
[ __ ] book and he did but the same
thing this Irish guy who said he did it
Frank yeah Aaron he also said he
sold the guns dude that killed JFK he
said he's done a bunch of stuff so
there's another book there great book
about richard kuklinski the ice man and
he did like he did the bull Gravano said
he's not even a [ __ ] anymore for the
Mafia a lot of these guys do kuklinski
they all say oh sure we'll cook Johnny a
light and and and [ __ ] a bunch of
hitmen were like this guy's a [ __ ]
this guy richard kuklinski the Iceman
there's a book by a guy named Philip
Carlo that wrote this book and kuklinski
was this polish guy from Jersey City and
he did he worked for all seven families
interval yet including New Jersey
watch his brother get beat to death in
front of him read that book it's so
[ __ ] crazy they made a really shitty
movie about him with Michael Shane
instead I was bummed out I was so high
skater making it as I loved Michael
Shannon but if you watch the old HBO
interviews so creepy so he's man nice so
they called the nice way because he
didn't give a [ __ ] but why do they all
say he was he was a piece of [ __ ] and
wasn't even in the Mafia might know hold
on keep going man I spent chin he was uh
no he flung his legit he didn't hurt but
everyone the Gambino's my Johnny a lie
and What did he say about Hoffa he said
he killed Hoffa in the book in the
interview he was like they I went to
Chicago I was in Chicago he tells how he
did it he said he stabbed him in the
back of the head kept the knife in then
they drove it to a [ __ ] compound law
got rid of the car in in the book The
Iceman by fellow Carlo and where does he
say the bodies that said he says he
doesn't know what in the steel and he
does near him though did the character
plan Cyrus man was friends with him but
the Irishman was also in Detroit at the
time with him all the time right
he kind of yes it confident for sure but
the other thing is you know when they
say he was buried under the giant
Stadium oh yeah the Yankee Stadium yeah
you so you know what they looked into
that there's so many the Mafia who did
all the construction for all the stadium
space in the East Coast
yeah they uprooted and went through it
they found so many bodies buried under
he's not reporting it that's so funny
because they're like in my field there's
why my bodies New York in the 70s and
80s they're like you want to put them in
the boys are guyline so the skyline on
20 and 20s I can meatpacking the word
it's like a beautiful place
now you walk up there it was a old
railroad thing ya do hi so how many
bodies up there right there wasn't just
homeless people it was like you know the
mob would just cuz again what brought
the mob to its knees video cameras just
catching them well but there you can't
kill people anymore yes they can trace
you with video cameras the cops is
called dude they do it they just draw a
line well now they've changed the inside
Afghan and heroin yeah they just kill
guys you know bodies were dropping off
in the Richard I bet if you went through
the East River um it just [ __ ]
trolled it all the skulls you would Paul
dude and the guns oh dude it's crazy but
that's what that's the thing about like
growing up in Colorado there's like a
history of Colorado that's maybe a
hundred and fifteen years old maybe
before it was Apache and Arapaho oh no
all the tribes that lieutenant Barnes
yeah Western Sioux you know just really
respecting the land being decent and
then white man coming through putting
down tracks but you go to New York
there's these buildings that are like
four hundred years old yeah five hundred
years old you're like oh I bet there are
by the hundred percent body you know
with Jimmy Hoffa with how they can't
find the body is it buried in Yankee
Stadium John same maybe but you know
they owned all the businesses so if they
did just you know set the body on fire
that makes most sense
we're fine but also you know what they
did some I guess the God is used to do
or can't be knows used to do is they
would take your body you kill you bleed
you yeah and then they cut you up oh
that's a groin a oh and the murder
mature you are both they throw you off
the boat and you'd be fish food yeah
well they do that up in little pieces
there's this place called Gemini Lounge
they used to be in Brooklyn in Roy DeMeo
and the MER it was called the murder
machine these like these assassins for
the Gambino family and the Gottis they
would just kill people and they had a
like a restaurant in the front and then
in the back was like kind of an
apartment and there was a bathtub
Kuklinski talks about him in his book
yeah and he said these guys would just
drip dry them like here and cut him open
and let them bleed out and then they
just take them out cut their hands there
well they also you said they also used
to put you and I the other thing they
did is they put you in a car masher so
they put you in the car where he says he
did with Hoff yeah yeah just
and you'd be under 50 tons of steel
never but he said he stabbed her in the
back of the head then put him in one of
those things and now he's just a cube of
[ __ ] matter I did read that way yeah
but kuklinski you want to hear that book
is a fun read is it super dark super
dark but you used to take I can read
gangsters killing gangsters I can't
really like I was reading the serial
killer book by Hunter it was so dark
because there's kids involved and have
kids I can't do it yeah gates on gain so
I'm all about it read that um it's a
good one there are a couple moments
where like he when he was a teenager and
he learned he just didn't care about
taking life and he talks about this in
the book animals first when he was a kid
yeah then in the [ __ ] 50s and 60s he
would go along the West Side Highway and
he would bump into homeless people and
whatever ones gave him attitude he would
hunt and kill that's how he practiced
but he had a family right loved his fans
right
loved his family his daughters loved his
daughters but then would beat the [ __ ]
out of his wife bad person yeah he's a
bad bad person but man what an
interesting [ __ ] my dad used to beat
the [ __ ] what did that beat his
brother to death in front of him when he
was five that's why he said he had no
what a failure there was seven and he
was five and watched his dad I'm not
sure that was in jail with him yeah he
had a younger brother too that was like
yeah he's just crazy
well change boy they dropped the ball in
the movie though really dropped it is so
good Michael Shannon's the [ __ ] of
course easy pick this roll up dude
picked it up grab dub bro let me do it
he worked for all seven families too cuz
he was polish so they're like oh you
could never beat a Hitler promoter so
he's kind of free a guy who'd just show
up and kill they said the first hit he
did they went to the West Village in
this one of the mobsters gave him a gun
it was like see that guy walking down
the street with his dog kill him
kolinsky just got out popped him in the
head got back in and the guy was like
what are you made of ice and that's
where like they started calling nice
mess he's shot him got back it was like
there you go is that what you wanted and
the guy's like trees what the [ __ ] what
the way his father destroyed him oh yeah
his father just cut the obviously turned
the light out inside that kid's head
yeah he was kind of like watch me make a
bush watch me make a machine little
piece of [ __ ] yeah father I got a piece
so hard yeah let's go to current events
it's the cyber monday sales everybody
oh dude commercial we did for them oh
yeah the ruthless on at 6:00 a tale of
death revenge and savings on it cyber
monday get it while you can on it comps
last fighter 10% off but you won't need
that 10% off because the cyber monday
sale is insane we're talking 60% off on
some stuff 25% off other stuff when you
spend over 100 200 hundred fifty or
spent 500 you get all sorts of sweet
perks everybody go to audit calm right
now it's their Cyber Monday you're
welcome you welcome current events let's
do some current of it okay so this was
submitted from David Lopez and the story
is that Pete Davidson is making his fans
sign an NDA prior to showing up to his
show and if they're in breach of this
NDA they can face up to a million
dollars in a Selma agreement because the
spoil that he's worried they're gonna
leak his jokes online so what you have
to do is prior to the day of the show
you have to assign the NDA or you get a
full refund that's very weird that is uh
you see him around New York and I've
known Pete since he was [ __ ] 15 years
old I like these two he's a sweetheart
I don't see him a lot anymore because I
think he's in like a different
stratosphere of like we're famous or I
think he like jet packs places and then
can leave or he's not like doing spots
not really but I just think this is so
funny if I tried doing this at like the
Albany funnybone Roma you guys got to
sign an NDA in the back so see your
comedy but we're not coming yeah I also
write more jokes also what are you doing
but I thought did so weird to me I think
what it is is what he's been is closely
associated with so many famous women now
people are like if he does a joke about
Ariana Grande
they're like he said Ariana Grande's
pussy's tunafish in the rain bit yes
because we also remember you know just
to defend a little bit is when you know
Mac Miller died right yeah dated ariana
grande a lot of people blamed him for
which there's no that's ridicuious and
he and I guess yeah the owner of the
club he was somewhere in New York might
be Caroline's I forget where but he told
the owner goes hey please don't mention
anything about it was
stress factory in Connecticut and it was
a journal in fact in New Jersey
yeah there's two there's one in
Connecticut he was doing the new one in
Connecticut again he was like don't
bring up who I'm dating
and then Vinny the guy went out there
and did that so he was like all right
[ __ ] this and I guess he came out to and
Sohn yelled out Mac Miller something
like use like you know I'm not gonna
talk about no he said my friend he's
like I had a friend of mine died in my
apartment and he's like Mac Miller and
he's like get the [ __ ] out of here you
hit the dude out yeah I mean I think
when you're that like in the tabloids
that's why I think Eddie Murphy coming
back is gonna be [ __ ] weird yeah how
do you work [ __ ] out I don't care the
clubs so dumb and some Democratic you
funny or not yeah
comedy doesn't give a [ __ ] about your
car you don't evolve now well I also
think like that's what's funny is when
you see comics that are feeling
themselves get around other comedians
and I'm like yeah don't give a [ __ ] no
you know what I mean I want to hang it
with Budetti Murphy what worries about
him is right maybe the greatest stand-up
of all time but what's worrisome about
that is we would see him you would hear
about him in clubs in New York we'd not
see him in LA does anyone see him doing
any work I've heard so many theories
like if you do a so many conspiracy
here's my Alan thing where he some
people write for him then just boom my
Thursdays I've heard a conspiracy theory
let's say that he's writing jokes having
other comedians try them and then he's
walked out we'd know about it I still
feel like we're know about it right I
feel like comics good job we're Chatty
Cathy we all wondered gossip Queens yeah
but I wrote a joke for Eddie Eddie
Murphy did you like that joke wrote it
Freddy also yeah I know that special I
have such a lack of confidence that if
it bombed I go why do you Murphy wrote
that and they're back Eddie I didn't
like Eddie told me to do that I paid to
do Eddie knows that he has to get that
get out there and do it you can't scare
doesn't matter where the or Netflix goes
here's a 100 mil he say
I'll come up with something yeah you
know but honestly the things you'll see
him anyway and we can all agree being
comics and I don't know as a fighter you
would know it's like the shitty part for
training to fight is running and getting
your wind up yeah shitty part about
comedies going on the road and doing the
rap huh you're doing but in clubs
getting five
you know one of the coolest conversation
like it that one of the coolest I love
it
one of the coolest conversations I've
ever seen in my life 2011 when I got
past the cellar ice at the table and I
heard Chris Rock explained Bobby Kelly
his theory on what Dane Cook needs to do
to get back on top what'd he say and he
said he needs to go to the clubs and
refined his funny
he said go sell out clubs and just
[ __ ] work on it in there do the road
work it do the road do the room and I
was like oh [ __ ] it was just crazy to
watch do you mean those anair about your
past what are you gonna do now it's
weight loss no one likes the solution
for weight loss which is always the same
exercise and diet or just stop [ __ ]
eat it but that's all that's the diet
sighs yeah comedy road work don't work
in clubs go fail a bunch yeah go over
Joker you like and then and they're like
[ __ ] to you and you sucks
and then you're like oh [ __ ] and then
three months later you like oh I added
that sentence suck my dick watch this
flame the room yeah it's not doing these
giant arenas once a month big-name
comics you gotta be Road music it really
is when you gotta skate like I've the
amount of time I've taken off since I
filmed this I was telling Brennan when
you were to the bathroom yeah [ __ ]
Brian's in the bathroom and spidering
the kid I go weird bathroom practice and
[ __ ] myself but they say though I taped
our I taped the special October 23rd and
now it's coming out December 7th and
it's one of those things where I've
taken time off the road that I feel
uncomfortable no I'm like I gotta
[ __ ] I got I got a handset yeah well
I'm thinking about right now is up in my
social media game get ready to sell out
[ __ ] miss boomers figuring it out
special tumor no I'm gonna call it
[ __ ] American and boner you should
call it here comes the Boomer here comes
Lou here comes the boom they're a great
movie what else yet gin so last week
Michigan was penalized for two of their
players untying and taking off the Ohio
State's running backs shoe they tack
them then they're trying to like buy
time though hello take your shoe off or
they have a foot fetish
he's goes that would [ __ ] me up so bad
if you're a pilot this one's different
oh this little piggys with my eyes watch
you run that way but I just had to suck
your toes look at this is so funny least
these two fatties do only way it would
have been funnier is if they somehow
tied his shoe strings together you know
like an old prank just like talking
around them they're right yeah that's
gonna find though that's so funny what
was the penalty 15 yards yep 15 means
stupid in hilarious yeah that's a cousin
penalty you're on TV it looks really
creepy though yeah it looks so crazy
sexual one guy number 37 reaches over
and just pulls in office what if what if
he doesn't it's an intimate luck but if
he tickled yeah
[ __ ] knock it off dude it's F so
weird what kind of song funny hot guys
[ __ ] stop it
watch my [ __ ] feet you weirdo I see
yet this one another literally seven
more minutes seven one minutes
young cuckoo Falcons Joker with that
same picker oh yeah all the creature
yeah apparently he did three on
sidekicks unbelievable and there's
there's something like there's only been
this season like too successful on
sidekicks yeah that's our centage of
science it's he's basically like uh he's
like a screwball pitcher you know what I
mean there's pitchers at this thing
there's like chaos and there is like
because he also missed a fuel bowl he
missed like two field goals in the game
but he got his three he got these three
and only get it on side but you know
what honestly if I'm an NFL coach and
you have the roster space and this guy
wants to
minimum or not to keep him on as an
onside kick er yeah just time do that
but not kick me then if he gets if your
kicker gets injured you got a backup
kicker how many times are you using on
yeah I don't know you I don't know
that's that's really where the [ __ ]
economics comes in yeah cuz that's
that's crazy
I watched it it was in sent and saying
he just kept getting it where they're
not being kickers man yeah I think
that's that's what's up that's the next
evolution Korean kickers and in black
airline pilots that's what I want to see
ya little Duval's pushing it and I like
it oh god he's pushing why did they
capitalize pilots at all three of them
well then the first one wasn't corps
after this yeah yeah they know they got
back in the in the game but they feel
like they did lose yeah by the way
Niners about to smash the Saints this
team that's got to go okay no cuz your
boy plays for you like dad my dad's from
the bay and so growing up it was dry I
got so many fistfights grown up in
Denver's and Joe Montana was better than
John Elway oh that's how I got into
fights elementary school middle school
back John oh is it a horse teeth like
what nothing Joe Montana what's up it's
a gift babe you know it wasn't it wasn't
a debate for me I was just on the
playground like [ __ ] your dad yeah dude
that's all my dad and I had so I've got
four rings
suck my dick Broncos and then to talk
[ __ ] to my cousins on my dad's side they
were like go warrior so I was like nah
go nuggets and they're like Denver
Nuggets I'm like Nuggets matumbo mother
yeah I just I just like to pick in the
side to be like on the outside looking
in you guys give us one more for Dennis
go one more what's your best one all
right how about this one there's a new
bow pick for Harriet Tubman that just
came out and I guess the screenwriter
said back in 94 when they're working on
it one of the studio execs said Julia
Roberts should do that's how he used to
work it but nobody here's the thing to
that studio execs I don't want to offend
him but they said basically he didn't
know who here at time it was so he tried
the story it was like that's fantastic
Oh Julia Roberts should play him and
even when the rooms all he didn't know
Harriet
and he's black he's like he doubled down
with I know that dude it was so long I
know that is so funny just to think of a
guy with a blue tooth in and he goes
alright here we go
I think Russell Crowe should play Matt
Turner I'm gonna hear it out I think
it's a great idea and they're like do
you know who Nat Turner is he's like I'm
sorry who is he
he let his slave revolt oh don't see why
Russell Crowe is he he was gladiator
he was gladion did gladiator work he's
not Greek and like thank you [ __ ]
Cruz played a samurai he's the last
several this is a classic example of a
Hollywood executive to stop saying
something to prove why they have a job
you know this isn't a creative type
who's like this could be a wonderful
story this is a guy who's like if I
don't speak right now they're gonna fire
Manson Julia Robert he's like what the
[ __ ] are you talking about you like I
love that you double dancing yeah oh
yeah I know France we put a chocolate
face oh no man she's got curly hair so
what was it 1994 I got the way we
started she's killing oh one other
process she was the biggest movie star
in the world yeah and she would have
been talking about slavery Jude rolling
I think it's a wonderful thing the couch
conversations all the late nights
because I know Harriet's black but I
feel like a change such an honor and I
thought I'd realize what it was like for
black just to know I just went I went
inside her body but I feel I asked do
blackface so I win when the Denzel
Washington won an Oscar and she goes she
ever notice you oh my god I'm gonna
knuckle [ __ ] myself to this later Denzel
Washington whoa whoa Julia Julia Julia
you're in you're in billions yeah dude
Forked season five great show let's see
that trailer for a special haven't seen
it it's uh I should tell you at the top
of this I'm an only child so I'm
guaranteed we're this is tough why I
just wanna watch yourself
that's great so they don't like into
actual punchline of that joke is that I
say my dad was a Jimmy Buffett fan and
he which is true and he died of
cirrhosis which is the parent head way
out and I was like my dad literally
wasted away in Margaritaville and we
tried to get Margaritaville to be the
final song that I walk off to yeah they
wouldn't do it
yo we sent it to Jimmy Buffett no no no
we send it to Jimmy Buffett's dude
we sent a clip and I wrote this like
elegant letter that's like mr. Buffett
my dad as a fan I just I would love bah
bah bah and we send it and I got two
texts from the dude first text is like
all of us got billions I read the letter
[ __ ] great letter second text just
watch the clip no no Jimmy doesn't like
joking around about as fans drink too
much and I like come on you made a
fortune office maybe sing let me have a
sip those shitty right Sipho sounds DJed
the special taping or whatever like he
was playing the music whatever and my
mom was there for both shows and at the
end of the show he just siphon himself
because he's funny he's a comedian and
he you know it's funny he just hit
Margaritaville as I walked off and I was
like aw it's really funny my mom is I
guess [ __ ] perfect and I was like oh
we should really do Margaritaville and I
was like gonna be such a good ending to
the special no such a bomb room yeah but
I think we should take his guy and get
him in a corner and give him a shove
around hey what's up dude is Jimmy Wow
what were you saying we did get Queens
of the Stone Age that's what's up that
was a dancer thanks for coming by thanks
for having me guys done really [ __ ]
Saturday yes Bo 10:00 p.m.
I'm gonna watch you say p.m. Eastern
sevens for us stream it everywhere son
of Gary Locke the six people that gave a
thumbs down on my favor Oh [ __ ]
love it dude roars finest man thinks my
brother's done in the hotel booking rule
yeah good man a town good that's great